problem I think is when having sex like
a man is seen as a default setting
because it doesn't suit the interests of
most women if we're saying that
something that suits the interests of
let's say five percent of women should
be the norm that inevitably is going to
mean that 95 percent are nudged by Shame
by social pressure now this episode is a
little bit different from our usual
programming because this is an interview
between me and Louise Perry who's the
author of the book the case against the
sexual Revolution the book in general is
intended as a critique of liberal
feminism and sometimes criticized by
conservatives and Christians for not
being conservative and Christian enough
now before we roll the interview it's
worth sharing a bit of a trigger warning
around this in that we do discuss topics
around sex and sexuality in a pretty
graphic way and we also talk about
issues including sexual assault and rape
and consent and so hopefully that's fair
warning if you'd rather not listen to
this episode I work for a campaign group
called we can't consent to this what we
do is we document cases where UK women
have been killed and their Killers have
claimed in court that they consented to
the violence which led to their deaths
so like the sex game gone wrong I think
that the focus on consent as the sole
framework for determining whether or not
sexual behavior is good or bad this is
completely inadequate there's so much
gray area between good sex and
consensual sex at the moment according
to the YouTube analytics 81 of you who
are watching this on YouTube have not
yet hit the Subscribe button and so if
you're for example in the now 81 of
people who are watching this on YouTube
but who are not subscribed to the
channel I would love it if you could do
so and would be awesome to get that
number down to 50 and it would be cool
to get like 50 50 sub non-sub ratio just
just for fun all right Louise thank you
so much for coming on the show thank you
for having me hello this is a very
interesting book the case against sexual
Revolution a new Guide to Sex in the
21st century how has it been doing I
guess the the media and publicity tour
of the book because it's I guess a
particularly sometimes controversial
topic yeah it's been better than I
thought you know
you while I was writing it
virtual
um that was kind of the idea but I would
say the response has been 90 to 95
positive okay which was much higher than
I thought what's the five to ten percent
like like what what what sort of what's
interesting is that it comes from every
possible angle which I think
I mean I think suggests I'm at least
being original even if I'm not right so
I mean so the book in general is a is is
intended as a critique of liberal
feminism so obviously liberal feminists
you know reiterate their point fine that
was that's to be expected I'm sometimes
criticized by
um conservatives and Christians for not
being conservative and Christian enough
okay because I have a chapter in there
that makes the case for marriage but
then I also have a whole bunch of other
chapters that they don't like as much
I have been criticized by
um radical feminists and some other
feminists for being too keen on
evolutionary psychology so completely
different groups or have a problem with
the book which I think is probably a
good sign yeah so
um up until I read this I did not really
realize that like uh liberal feminists
and like radical feminists and sex
positive and negative feminine was was
like a thing yeah um what do these kind
of terms mean what's extra confusing is
everyone calls themselves different
things feminism is like an infamously
factional movement
um I write about liberal feminism in the
books the term I chose to use even
though people wouldn't fully be more
likely to describe themselves as
intersectional feminists I mean liberal
feminism is basically the feminism of
like Cosmo Emma Watson okay it's what
you'll you'll most commonly come across
in the guardian okay it's it's like it's
like the mainstream position nowadays
the main idea about liberal feminism is
basically that giving women freedom and
giving women choice is the most
important thing
and that the what was wrong about the
past the pre-feminine stage was that
women didn't have their choices
constrained
and post 1960s we've seen this sort of
explosion of freedom and that's a great
thing
which I disagree with radical feminism
is a it's faded away a little bit it was
more prominent in the 70s and 80s and
that is
um
as the name suggest more radical version
of feminism which says that
um
women are an oppressed class like it's
like it's like a Marxist framework where
women and men are different classes and
Men necessarily oppress
women
I used to be much more sympathetic to
radical feminism I've moved away from it
somewhat
um but yeah these are these are factions
who are at each other's throats okay a
lot I'm happy for a long time a sex
positive and sex negative like what is
how does that time so sex positive
liberal feminist I think are pretty much
always sex positive and what does sex
positive mean so the the kind of Steel
Man of sex positivism is is it's the
idea that there's nothing
inherently shameful about sex that a lot
of particularly Christian ideas about
sex are very oppressive and they they
you know they make people miserable
um and that actually take having a kind
of generally positive regard towards sex
and saying that look as long as you can
sense as long as people are all
adults or whatever then what's the
problem yeah I think the problem with
the sex positive view is it Shades very
very easily from that General we should
be generally positive towards it sounds
lovely the problem is that it Shades
very easily into actually being into
these things actually becoming almost
compulsory
so that we we go from saying women
should be allowed to have one night
stands there's nothing wrong necessarily
with having one night stands fine I
think that anyone who's brought up in a
vaguely liberal environment is going to
agree with that but then I think that
the the point that we've come to now is
that actually not having one night
sounds is weird
going through a period of your life
having one night stands as a route
towards a monogamous relationship which
is what most women say they want what
most men actually also say they want
eventually
is almost like running the gauntlet and
I think that what sex positive feminism
does in practice even if not in theory
is it provides
provides cover for a culture that is
actually very coercive
because we are all networked individuals
we all make choices in context but
influenced by other people and I think
particularly when it comes to sex
because sex necessarily is something you
do with other people so you're going to
be influenced by everyone else and I
think to say that to focus only on the
individual yeah and to think only about
our own choices in isolation
and the idea that we should you know
regard all those choices positively
I think massively neglects the ways in
which our choices are constrained in
practice what do you mean by the ways in
practice
so one example would be if you
pre the pill right the standard route
for young women particularly if you come
from
kind of respectable background let's say
is not to have sex poor marriage that's
the default you know and it means if you
you talk to women who grew up in that
era they'll say you know yes of course
there were instances where that didn't
happen teenagers being as they are
but equally it was it was the assumed
thing and if you you know when I was
late with a boy or whatever he knew that
that was he knew that was a hard limit
you didn't have to negotiate on it
whereas now I'd say that that has
flipped and now the assumption is that
you're put out
not necessarily on a first day although
increasingly you know straight away
and and the default therefore becomes a
yes
okay and that's the site at which you
have to negotiate and often you know
it's very difficult because you're doing
that within the context of you don't
want to refrigerator you don't want to
be approved you don't want to lose
social status
and so I think to say that you have a
choice yeah you do of course we'll have
choices we'll have free will
but if you're in a culture that says
that putting out on a first day is
normal
teenagers in particular care a lot about
being normal and that is the site which
our choices are constrained
so so it sounds like
yeah so I mean and please correct me if
this is not a fair summary of um of your
position but it sounds like you're
saying that in an absolutely dream world
of course
we would have uh we would have we
wouldn't be using the uh the weapon of
Shame against uh women or men or anyone
to constrain their behavior and people
will do what they want in a consensual
fashion and everything is all fine and
dandy because actually people are as you
know uh Ayla was saying in the debate
you had with her checking in with
themselves in isolation and saying how
do I personally feel about this there
are some women who will enjoy having sex
with multiple partners some women who
won't and everything all goes because
Society is non-judgmental it sounds like
you're saying in the real world those
kind of that that kind of dream world
doesn't really exist not only that but I
think the war on shame is a complete
dead end okay I think I mean not just in
relation to sex and relationship
everything of course we shame is
basically the term we use to describe
any means of social control that isn't
actually implemented through laws and
police and whatever right yeah
um we are shamed for being dishonest
we're ashamed for you know there are all
sorts of things that we're ashamed about
we don't necessarily use that term
because it is very loaded but I don't
know the shame that people feel about
being raised there's a new a newer form
of Shame and a good form of Shame you
should feel ashamed of being racist you
know so I think that the idea of doing
away with shame entirely is not only
impossible but also I think bad
the the question though is what we
should be attaching shame to and I agree
with Ayla when she says that we should
um
you know women should be allowed to to
if if women really sincerely like
behaving as men have historically
behaved you know having sex like a man
is the phrase I use in the book fine I
completely agree the problem I think is
when having sex like a man is seen as an
ideal and as seen as a as a default
setting because it doesn't suit the
interests of most women if we're saying
that something that suits the interests
of let's say five percent of women
should be the norm that inevitably is
going to mean that 95 are nudged by
Shame by social pressure
one of the early chaps so it was it was
kind of funny when when I first got
introduced to your book um because I
have this other podcast that I do with
my brother uh and we just sort of treat
it as a bit of a chit chat and he came
across your book a few months ago this
was just before I DMD on Twitter and we
just sort of read their chapter titles
sex must be taken seriously chapter two
men and women are different chapter
three some desires are bad chapter four
Loveless sex is not empowering consent
is not enough violence is not love
people are not products and marriage is
good and then the conclusion listen to
your mother it was just like kind of
funny because immediately we knew that
wow this is it's it's really clever in
that some people are going to think it's
like oh my God this is you're this is
like hate crime and some people are
going to think this is totally
reasonable wisely why do you need to
write a book about it yeah um how did
yeah how did how did the naming of the
chapters come about it actually went a
couple of months before the book was
published in the UK it's not out yet in
America it will be in a few weeks
um the contents page the publisher just
uploaded the contents page and the cover
to the side no other no other details
and it provoked a minor Twitter storm
well quite a major drift still I'm
actually lasting several days because of
exactly this because some people looked
at those chapter titles and thought this
woman is a fascist right and then other
people said hang on what am I missing
here and that exact kind of Clash of
opinion yeah was uh explosive it's it's
interesting just kind of reading through
these because having having read the
book now I could I can sort of trace the
logic of your argument through just the
chapter headings which is kind of nice
so I wonder if we can start with sex
must be taken seriously I guess when I
first read that chapter it reminded me
of a thing that I was
thinking and saying in conversations at
University when like all of my friends
all my female friends would have
identified as intersectional feminists
um this was sort of 2014 2015 era and
there was a lot of stuff going on that
oh
feminism or sort of white feminism is
bad because it doesn't take into account
like uh race and class and uh the trans
debate hadn't quite caught on back in
2014 but now I'm sure intersectional
feminists would include the trans stuff
as part of the thing but putting all
that aside
um the way I was thinking about
sort of sex from a I guess ethical moral
philosophical standpoint was the phrase
having sex should be just as you know
just the same as playing squash with
someone you wouldn't bat an eyelid if
you're playing squash at someone as long
as both parties are consenting and it's
mutual then hey anything goes why are we
all making a big fuss about the sex
thing religion is a little bit backwards
because like come on guys sex is just
like playing squash
um and your first chapter sex must be
taken seriously you talk about this idea
of sexual disenchantment and I wonder
like what's what's going on there so
I've borrowed the secretary's
enchantment phrase from um an American
writer called Aaron savarium who
borrowed it from Max Weber
who described the process of
disenchantment during the Enlightenment
whereby people used to believe that
nature was filled with you know Spirit
agency and then posts Scientific
Revolution we we come to believe that
actually it's all just kind of
scientific forces and there's no there's
no there's no specialness there's no
sacredness it's just kind of like blunt
physical forces kind of clashing
together and sex resistant Shaman is
sort of the same thing it comes out in
the 1960s and it's the idea that sexy
used to have a sec a sacred status I
mean in all religious Traditions pretty
much sex has some sort of special
significance as some ritual associated
with it in Christian tradition uh sex
has to take place within marriage which
is a Sacrament and then that all falls
away
and now the idea is exactly as you say
that sex shouldn't it can have special
meaning if people want to give it
special meaning power to them but in the
Bare Bones it really is just like
playing squash with someone shaking
someone's hand making coffee whatever
kind of neutral social interaction you
want to describe I think there are two
problems with the sexual disenchantment
idea the first is that it's nonsense no
one actually behaves as if that were
true right like people don't care if
their Partners go and play squash with
someone else people care deeply if their
Partners have sex with someone else and
even when they're trying really hard not
to feel that way it's a very common
occurrence in the polyamorous Community
or you know any like poly
platform you want to go to online you'll
find people who are desperately
struggling with jealousy so this is even
when it's not just a case of breaking
the contract of the marriage exactly
it's an easy defense yeah exactly it's
not that your partner is being deceitful
or anything like that it's just that you
have this deep visceral response to your
partner having sex with someone else in
a way that of course you would not have
to any of these other kind of neutrals
so in my relationship contract if I if I
if I happen to have a clause saying that
you know we're only going to play squash
with one another and then my girlfriend
plays squash with someone else the fact
that yes it's a Breaking of the con I
wouldn't feel as bad about clearly a
stipulation yeah you know yeah it
clearly has a different kind of
emotional resonance doesn't it yeah yeah
people don't behave as if sexually
disenchantment was true similarly if
your boss asks you to do something
that's not in your job description right
if you're asked to I don't know make
them coffee is the example I give in the
book or you're asked to do overtime or
you're asked to do you know something
that's not like strictly listed within
your your duties fine that's normal like
we I think we've all had experiences
like that if your boss asks you to give
him a [__] that's completely
different everyone knows that's
completely different and the feminists
who who are loudest and insisting that
sex can be just like playing squash are
the first to say that of course your
boss shouldn't be asking you to give him
a [__] right because we know that
actually this isn't like a neutral there
is something there is something special
we know we might not want to use West
sacred but there is something special
about sex which means that people just
have a wholly different emotional
response to it so on that front um you
know if we compare like a boss asking
you to work overtime versus boss asking
you to give him a [__] clearly those
things are very very very different yeah
what would the Steel Man uh feminist say
in this situation if they weren't trying
to use sacredness and specialness of sex
as a reason as to why this feels
different so they might say that um
there's a kind of imbalance between men
and women
um which means that there's a power
Dynamic at play
which makes that request more kind of
charged okay than it would be
um then some other interaction would be
I guess in I I guess they might compare
it to something like the imbalance
between someone who's rich and someone's
poor and the sort of inherent tension
based on that power differential
differential
um
you can't really apply that to two men
if a male boss asks his male Junior
employees give him a [__] that's also
really bad yeah okay so what would I
think that was a part on that basis
I think the problem is just that it's
very difficult to rationalize it's it's
not something you can kind of easily
line up in a logical argument but the
fact is people feel differently about
sex and they do about other things and
as far as we can tell people have always
felt that way
and that's just a that's just like a
component of human life that we have to
reckon with and I think the problem
we're trying to explain it away and say
oh with this you know whatever people
have these deep riskeral feelings but
they are somehow wrong too is that I
think that down the line that's really
bad for women and I think it's bad for
everyone but I think it's particularly
bad for women because
um
if you don't think that sex has a
special status it's very hard to explain
why rape would have a special status
why would it have a special status aside
from theft you know or some other kind
of neutral
yeah I mean you might say that it's it's
more like violating a bodily autonomy
than something like theft is
but I guess if you wouldn't compare it
to I don't know getting stabbed or
something like it it just
and so are when you when you first said
the [__] thing on Chris Williamson's
podcast so he's a friend of mine um
I was I found myself
trying to run circles around my own
brain to figure out like there's got to
be a reason why this thing is bad other
than saying oh because sex is just
special like because that feels like
a is such an obvious answer but also
feels like the answer that I I'm almost
loathed to concede that point that like
there must be like power dynamics oh but
I think because it runs very counter to
um the liberal Paradigm which is all
about
um rationalizing human behavior
but it's it's often been observed that
um radical feminists so that's
feministic come out of the second wave
and tend to have this kind of marxist
analysis of the relationships between
men and women reach many of the same
conclusions as Catholics and some other
religious groups who the Catholics in
particular Catholics they oppose
um prostitution porn sorry to see you
know whatever you want to pick like they
are they are often in agreement although
not entirely with radical feminism and
I've often had
um
uh academics and other
um analysts think asking why that would
be like what possible why would radical
feminists have anything in common with
Catholics
and it's often used against radical
feminists as well as kind of a
suggestion that they're somehow like
secretly completely conservative I think
the reason that they reach the same
conclusion actually
is not because they are unusual it's
because the liberal
secular alternative is unusual
in that they they recognize the
specialness of sex
they agree that for whatever reason
people have this very very strong
Instinct of you sex is special in the
same way that we have a very strong
instinct to like love our children or
any other manner of slightly strange
irrational response right
um it's just a given this is just how
people feel and I think if you start
with that prior then you are going to
end up particularly if you're really
concerned about the well-being of women
and of children you're going to end up
opposing things like porn and I think
the reason that
people people's attempts to deny the
specialness of sex where they end up
being much more permissive
it comes from that prior but I think I
think the prior is a problem and I think
also that people are really inconsistent
on it people will say simultaneously
that whatever sex is like playing squash
but then they won't behave as if that's
the case yeah yeah one of the other
interesting examples that you talk about
in the book is this this situation and
uh I hadn't come across this before so
you just really sort of threw me for one
when when you posted in the book this
idea of
um
essentially sexual favors in return for
rent yeah yeah what's like what's the
what's the what's the story here
um yeah it had some media attention
during the pandemic because it became
landlords started doing it more
um it's basically the problem when when
uh landlords were advertised often
surreptitiously
um that they'll offer free or reduced
rent in exchange for sexual favors from
young attractive tenants right and
I have I don't think I've ever come
across anyone who thinks that's fine
yeah aside from the like handful of
landlords who might propose it
themselves like all political party in
the UK uh unanimously it's just like so
obviously a terrible thing right yes but
then I and and I think it's very
striking that say the liberal Democrats
are really opposed to
the sex for rent and there's been
various calls to have like bespoke
offenses
criminalizing
um criminalizing the advertising of it
but they want to decriminalize the sex
industry
Annie and Jeremy corbyn similarly was
opposed to sex for rent but also has
said on the record that he thinks that
decriminalizing sex work would be the
more civilized option that was the
expression he used
I'm like Laz this is the same thing
you're just exchanging one form of
economic good for another if you if you
want to say that a
um a tenant is far too vulnerable to be
exchanging
sex in exchange for housing or if you
want to say that there is just something
grubby and exploitative and sexist and
whatever about even proposing this
as an arrangement
how can you possibly say that it's fine
as long as it's cash
it just doesn't make sense to me cash
can be exchanged for rent so it's like
literally just removing it intermediary
exactly but clearly something about it
feels really really bad I think it's
because it highlights what's going on I
think it's because
um
I think that we've been sold a bit of a
fantasy about what the sex industry
looks like
um
a lot of people don't have any contact
with the sex industry they probably
never knowingly spoken to they will have
spoken to sex buyers in their lives
because there are enough of them around
but probably they wouldn't know about it
and they probably won't have
have spoken to
um people in prostitution so a lot of
what we think about what with a lot of
what we think about sex industry comes
from fiction
um things like Diary Of A Call Girl
would be a very typical portrayal of the
sex industry and a very unrepresentative
one it's not to say that there aren't
examples of high class call girls who
have unusual experiences in the industry
but it's absolutely not the norm
um I think part of the reason I
um
I take a different view from the
standard view the sex industries because
of actually speaking to women who've
been in it at the at the Grim end right
not up there not at the the high end at
the at the worst end where actually most
of the women are to be found right
um
so I think that's part of the reason why
people tend to have a slightly more
permissive rhetorical stance on it
whereas I think with sex for rent it's
just so obvious what's going on
particularly in the middle of a housing
crisis is it people are desperate
you can so easily imagine how someone
could be coerced into that kind of
really explosive and dangerous situation
I also do wander a bit like a lot of the
reporting on sex around
it's about University cities and about
the possibility of students being
trapped in this kind of arrangement
because we know of course the students
are don't have very much money
and I can't help but think that part of
what's going on there is class as well I
think there's that feeling that
the women who end up actually in like
normal prostitution are poor almost
always right and it doesn't feel as if
like it's something that could
realistically happen to middle class
women whereas a landlord making a sleazy
request of you does feel like it could
happen to middle class women so I can't
help but think that there's an element
of like self-interest there oh yeah
that's just me being cynical there we
are all right we're just going to take a
quick break from the podcast to
introduce our sponsor which is huel now
this is very exciting because I've
actually been a pain customer of huel
since 2017. I started eating Hill in my
fifth year of medical school and I've
been using heal regularly ever since
because you know I like to be productive
I you know if my calendar is full with a
lot of things and often I don't have the
time or don't make the time to have a
particularly healthy breakfast or a
particularly healthy lunch and heal is
fantastic for those occasions because
it's 400 calories they've got tons and
tons of different flavors my favorite
flavor is salted caramel because for
that you get 400 calories you also get
40 grams of protein super hard to get
enough protein in my diet these days
especially with trying to get hinge and
working out he'll just make sure that I
get at least those 40 grams in the 400
calories and it's got 26 different
vitamins and minerals which really helps
with the whole healthy balanced diet
thing as well now I don't use heal with
every meal I wouldn't recommend using it
with every meal but in those occasions
where you find yourself reaching for a
very unhealthy snack we're about to
order a really unhealthy takeaway it's
just absolutely fantastic being able to
have the option now I use the heel black
edition in the mornings it's very nice I
put two scoops of powder into my little
blender type thing Add Water sometimes a
bit of milk and that gives me what I
need but also for lunch I like using the
huel hot and savory product they've got
which basically you add boiling water to
this container of stuff and you can make
yourself like a they've got a really
good cheese pasta type one which is
which is my favorite thing and again
also all of these are nutritionally
complete meals they're all vegan they
all have all these nutrients and
vitamins and minerals and stuff and
they're often reasonably high protein as
well and it's also ridiculously cost
effective like one of these meals is one
pound 68 for a 400 calorie meal which is
like a tenth of the price of what I
would be ordering from deliveroo instead
and to really heal is a perfect
companion for a busy life where you want
to get a lot of things done and you
don't if you don't necessarily have a
lot of time to cook a healthy meal and
deal with all the prep and all the
shopping and all the cleanup then heal
is a great addition to your life rather
than a replacement for all of the meals
in your life anyway if that sounds
appeal Street and you want to try out
heal then if you head over to heel.com
forward slash deep dive that URL is a
special URL which will give you a free
t-shirt and a free Shaker thing with
your first order and so yeah head over
to heel.com forward slash deep dive and
thank you so much Hill for sponsoring
this episode this episode is very kindly
brought to you by trading 212. now
people ask me all the time for advice
about investing because I've made a
bunch of videos about it on the YouTube
channel and my advice for most people is
generally invest in Broad stock market
index funds which is exactly what you
can do completely for free with trading
212. it's a great app that lets you
trade stocks and funds and ETFs and
foreign exchange if you really want to
and one of the great things about the
app is that if you're new to the world
of investing you can actually invest
with fake money you don't have to put
real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tube into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want now if
you're based in the UK you might be
familiar with the concept of an Isa
which is an individual savings account
which is basically a tax-free wrapper
that you can put money in you can put 20
000 pounds in every year up to twenty
thousand pounds and it resets every
April and then all that money can and
grow and it's completely tax-free for
the rest of your life and if you want to
sign up for an iso you can sign up for
one completely for free also on
trading212 so if you haven't yet filled
up your eyes allowance or at least put
some money into your Isa for this year
that might be a good step forward the
app also lets you Auto invest which is a
great thing because then you can
automatically invest a percentage of
your paycheck into the thing every month
and so if you haven't yet started with
investing and you want to give it a go
then you can download the app on the App
Store and if you use the coupon code Ali
Ali at the checkout that will give you a
totally free share worth up to 100
pounds it's available on iPhone and
Android and you can check it out by
typing in trading212 into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading212 for sponsoring this
episode I'm going to pose a hypothetical
here let's so
um these days uh Society at large
considers something like only fans to be
a totally reasonable form of side hustle
for mostly women yeah um I don't think
there are many men on only fans there
are some of the most you have male
clients okay yeah
um but only fans is considered a
reasonable side hustle because of course
sex workers work and just like I debate
myself on the internet through YouTube
videos uh you know what's really the
difference between that and only fans
it's all consensual et cetera Etc yeah
and then you have people like uh
Alo who are kind of sort of outspoken
about how great a lifestyle this is and
how actually being sort of women having
the ability to make money through
something like only fans where they have
zero risk of violence because it's all
through the internet and where the
alternative might be working in a really
Grim Factory so why not allow women this
this opportunity
let's put that as like on the one hand
and then if we sort of add in this sort
of uh sex for rent situation whereby
hypothetically if a landlord would say
you know what I don't want you to have
sex with me I just want to I just want
you to be a sort of webcam girl for me
and in return I'll give you a discounted
rent
I would still feel really weird yes and
and
it's still there's something about that
that still feels really Sleazy and not
nice and bad compared to if that
landlord happened to be a pain client on
her only fans account
and it's just the relationship was just
less obvious even though he's paying her
money in fact if he's getting a discount
on rent
what's going on yeah why does it feel so
bad in that situation maybe it's because
it feels much more real and immediate
you know what it also is probably to
some extent things like Diary of
Secretary of a call girl that kind of
thing I mean it's always really
interesting whenever you see
um either fictional portrayals or you
see media reports on the sex industry
you know the classic photo they use in
the sex industry is like a woman in a
short skirt leaning into a car like the
photos are always of typically sort of
headless women
um in sexy outfits you never see photos
of the clients
I can't remember her name now off the
top of my head but there's this um
German woman who did a a project where
she took photos of
sex buyers because in Germany it's legal
so they have sort of nothing to fear
from being photographed so she did this
series of portraits of sex fires I mean
partly to demonstrate the fact that they
are you know old young fat thin whatever
like the whole range of men but also
like they're not attractive generally
kind of by definition if you're seeking
out sex with someone who you have to
coerce through payment like there's a
good chance it's because she wouldn't
otherwise have sex with you right these
guys are not attractive and I think that
I think it's actually important to
remember that not have it as this kind
of fantasy Arrangement where you've got
like a sexy guy and a dinner suit or
whatever that you might see on the TV
like these are the the the the the line
I've I've heard from um Rachel Moran who
is a writer she wrote this amazing
Memoir called paid for without being a
prostitution
um
is if you want to know what it actually
feels as a woman to to like really
imagine what it would be like to be in
prostitution go into any bar cafe Pub
whatever look around at every man in
your vicinity and imagine having sex
with all of them
like no choice right it doesn't matter
how much you fancy them and I wonder if
thinking about having a sex friend or a
nudes for rent Arrangement or whatever
with your landlord is we all think of
like our last landlord and we think no
no thank you yeah I guess it brings to
relief what's actually going on exactly
whereas like a visceral reminder of what
it means with like an anonymous field of
like only fans viewers or Shoppers and
stuff it just sort of separates that out
yeah
um the argument I make in the book for
why
um prostitution invariably causes trauma
to women in particular in it is um you
know it's partly the fact it's
extraordinarily dangerous and it is and
has very high rates of violence of every
kind
um but also I think I think the reason
it's
invariably experience is traumatic with
a few exceptions at Ayla for instance
although Ayla actually did has she
stopped doing in-person sex work right
so she didn't she didn't like it very
much but anyway
um is because a very very deep-seated
Instinct within women which has a very
obvious and
um
and clear evolutionary background is
that we really care a lot about who we
have sex with like make choices very
very important which doesn't make sense
if you understand the fact that men and
women have different making strategies
and the
it's very much in women's interest to be
picky about who they get pregnant by
because pregnancy is
extremely demanding on the body
dangerous labor is dangerous you then
have a baby to look after for how many
how many years afterwards which is
abundant newborn on your community
um you don't want to get pregnant by
some bozo
who's gonna who either has terrible
genes or is going to abandon you so that
that desire to invest wisely you know
sexual partners is very very deep-seated
and what prostitution does is it
violates that choice you you don't have
the option you don't have the the make
choice is removed from your power and I
think that is
a big part of the reason why it has this
very very
deeply felt emotional
response yeah so I think like with all
these different hypotheticals and
scenarios and stuff I mean the
conclusion of chapter one is essentially
sex must be taken seriously because sex
is in fact a special good Beyond a
coffee or a handshake or staying late at
work it's like this special thing yeah
and we might not be able to explain
exactly why it's a special thing using
the liberal moral ideology but we all
just kind of know it is like it's it's
something that feels very unfashionable
to say out loud but everyone just knows
it like no one actually behaves as if
sex is as irrelevant as getting someone
a coffee precisely which segues US
nicely into um unique uh chapter two
which is men and women are different
what's uh what's going on there I guess
kind of we're thinking physically and
also psychologically and like
emotionally
um physically it's Pro I mean even even
that is it should be obvious yeah it
isn't necessarily the obvious thing is
just in the sense that women are the
ones who get pregnant
um which means that in any heterosexual
encounter there's that asymmetry
um
also the fact that women are much
smaller and weaker than men but like a
surprising degree I think people I think
I
think it's become easier
to trivialize that difference because we
live in a modern world where strength
differences aren't as obvious and even
you can like if you don't have siblings
and you don't go to the gym and you
don't do any manual work you can go like
quite a long way without realizing
that like your sibling is going to
thrash you in a fight if you if you're
if if he's male and you're female you
know particularly post puberty because
different upper body differences for
instance between men and women are are
wild I think it's like a factor of two
the male punching strength is twice as
forceful as female on average and it's
one of those things if you look at if
you look at like a scatter graph showing
different individuals like yes there are
some isolated examples
not as many as you might think though
and definitely the extreme End by
Olympians for instance
like if if women didn't have a
protective category in the Olympics they
just wouldn't even make it anywhere
close to
actually competing in the games
um because the difference is that Stark
which matters obviously right so if
you're talking about like going home
with the randomer
if if a man over man or woman are alone
together the man just inherently is
going to have
a physical Advantage
um combined with the fact that the woman
is the one who risks getting pregnancy
who who suffers the risks associated
with things like hormone work control
there are just a whole bunch of ways in
which women are a disadvantage in that
kind of scenario yeah yeah this uh this
idea that men and women are different
was pretty unfashionable when I was at
University and I'm not sure to what
extent it still is having been out of
University now for several years
um but often
I would find that when I was talking to
people about this I'd be using the
phrase uh I I I'd be using the idea of
averages and the idea of a normal
distribution would just like an innate
understanding of what a normal
distribution is yeah and yet people
would always say oh but my friend is six
foot three and she's she could take any
man in a fight and be like okay people
can be really dumb about that yeah like
what's what's going on there scientists
it's funny isn't it uh yeah because
people will tend to just come up with
exceptions
um
and of course there's exception success
like this completely I'm completely
willing to incorporate exceptions into
this whole analysis
um it is funny how people tend not to do
it about more and morally neutral things
like height for instance we're happy to
accept that men are taller than women
on average even if they're at all women
and there are some short men like the
difference is massive
um
similarly on other physical differences
and I mean the psychological ones is the
one that people really get upset about
and obviously psychological differences
are much more amenable to cultural
influence and physical ones
um
still there's loads of evidence and the
evidence accumulates more and more
because we now have more sophisticated
research methods that makes it clear
that these there are some important
differences to men and women on average
and they hold true cost cross-culturally
so I guess
um you know we could we can go into the
psychological differences in a moment
but I I guess someone listening to this
might be thinking okay fine but like why
does on average even matter like why do
I personally care about the average I'm
not necessarily the average man or the
average woman yeah uh at one point A
friend of mine gave dating advice to me
saying that you know uh on average women
prefer men who uh are sort of come
across as more masculine and therefore
wear a black T-shirt in your Tinder
profile picture isn't like don't sing
those Disney songs and have Harry Potter
posters in your house because the
average woman will think that it's not
particularly masculine it's not
particularly alpha male kind of Vibes
and I mentioned this on a podcast where
I'm sort of just in passing it all the
comments oh my God I can't like this is
such a stupid way of thinking like
obviously you know you aren't trying to
appeal to the average you're trying to
appeal to in in an individual you should
be yourself etc etc yeah where do you
see the balance of like how much should
we care about on average versus actually
treating individuals as individuals
so
on an individual level people might make
decisions unique to their situation and
that would be fine the problem is when
you're talking about population level
and you're talking about
laws obviously the legal system applies
to everyone regardless of where you're
wrong curve
um but also applying to to Norms right
because my argument in the book is that
we used to have quite an elaborate set
of norms relating to regulating
sex relationships between men and women
and we've mostly done away with them and
left just the consent framework standing
and I don't think the consent framework
is good enough
I'm saying that actually things like you
know if you have a norm that is
something like mention hit women
I mean the law says that too but just in
terms of what what's considered to be
socially acceptable there are all sorts
of things that are against law people do
anyway right like speeding people's
people's time Etc if you have a really
rock solid normal you say men hitting
women is really bad but women hitting
men it's not good but it's not quite as
bad like that's asymmetrical clearly
um and there might be examples of a
woman who really belts a man and you
know he's small and frail and that's and
that's like very dangerous but
the reason that you would have that
slightly that slightly
um different standard is because of
recognizing the fact that these average
differences exist and at the population
level a man hitting a woman is much more
likely to kill her than a woman hitting
a man
because most men can kill most women
with their bare hands and the reverse is
not true and that matters as a great
deal when you're thinking about
um
yeah relationships through men and women
yeah yeah I think that was the thing
that really struck me with the debate
that you had with uh
Ayala on that unheard YouTube channel
podcast show thing where
seemed like you were both sort of saying
the same thing but what she was saying
was a lot of kind of but let's take the
individual into account yeah and it
sounded like you were saying okay but if
we're making laws and deciding norms for
a whole society we can't just take
individuals into account we have to with
all of the
all of the cap all of the downsides
associated with broad brush Strokes
we've got to draw a broad brush Strokes
Somewhere yeah we have to and so yeah
why not do that in a way that protects
women rather than that
I guess protects the interests of the
huefeness of the world as as you say in
the book yeah have you come across Rob
Henderson's idea of luxury beliefs uh
only in the book I recently followed him
on Twitter so I want to get into more of
his his stuff yeah
um so his idea of luxury beliefs it's
very it's it's
a fabulous idea it has so much
explanatory power is um
his theory is that
um as luxury goods have become cheaper
it used to be a way of for the elites to
Signal their wealth would be to own
whatever precious item
the
one of the consequences of globalization
is that a lot of these Goods become
cheaper and his theory is that to some
extent Elite the Elite Class have
pivoted towards other means of
demonstrating their Elite status that
are not just sort of material and one
example of this is luxury beliefs so a
luxury belief is a belief that confers
status on on Elite people and the costs
of it are born entirely by
poor people no okay so what's an example
so the example that's most relevant for
us
is polyamory
so Rob
um gives the example of being in a
university town and setting your Tinder
location to like a mile radius and
you'll find loads and loads of women at
Harvard Oxford whatever
um who will say that they are Polly
they're interested in open relationships
they're doing this kind of you know
Bohemian thing which is increasingly
fashionable
um and uh it's a way of them advertising
their sexiness and their rebelliousness
and so on in a way that tracks partners
and you know confers status
but then he describes setting your
Tinder ratio let's say in city like
Oxford to like 10 mile radius
and then you start seeing women
who are single mothers right who are
living the life who are living the
consequences of disregarding monogamous
marriage as an institution
and like suffering for it being a single
mother is really tough in all sorts of
ways and they didn't get any status for
that at all right like living the
polyamorous life if you're poor and you
live on a council estate is not his
status at all and actually causes all
sorts of destructive effects in your
life whereas if you're rich you can be
poly and you can basically pick up the
pieces if everything goes wrong because
you have that kind of buffer around you
that's conferred by wealth and conferred
by status
um
it's really it's a really useful idea
and I think that that applies to I mean
it does apply to something like
um what ayla's talking about in relation
to prostitution so she has an unusual
experience of it not always a good
experience but you know better than many
and she describes it as being a lot
better than for instance working in the
total factory job that she used to do
and I respect that I completely
recognize the fact that in her
individual case that may be true the
problem is she's experienced the the
collect tippy-toppy end of the best form
of prostitution through only fans and
other you know caming whatever there's
much less violence and she has quite
good money she's not pimped like every
possible Dimension is better than it
might otherwise be
and the problem is that if we're going
to legislate or or construct Norms
around ayla's experience and do as many
you know intersectional feminists and so
on do and talk about sex work being work
which is a luxury belief right it's the
sort of thing that if you say that in a
university common room it will confer
status on you or make you look
um open-minded and liberal and Bohemian
and all of this stuff right
um it might be good for some women like
Ayla it's not going to be good for a
woman at the opposite end of the scale
because the argument I make around
um decriminalizing the sex industry
I mean bearing in mind that all legal
models in relation to the sex industry
are like better and worse trade-offs
it's a difficult it's just a difficult
thing to legislate for inherently but I
think the the key problem with
decriminalizing demand making it legal
to pay for sex is that there aren't
actually enough women like like Ayla
whoever who are willing to meet that
demand most women really really don't
want to be in prostitution they'll only
do it if they're very poor or if they're
otherwise coerced and the problem is
that in societies where
um buying sex is legal more men do it
obviously like the difference is quite
apparent between a country like like in
Thailand for instance like amazingly
High proportion of men by sex
um in Germany
um since the legalization of sex
industry the proportion of German men
who have bought sex has gone up a lot
and the pro and it becomes routine
things like stag do is you'll go to a
you'll go to a brothel right which is
not considered normal in countries where
it's criminalized
um is you need to meet that demand you
need women who can
who can who can supply the sex that has
been demanded and that's when you get
things like increases in trafficking so
legalization is associated with an
increase in trafficking because
they Define women who can you know meet
this demand and make money for them and
so what sounds like a great open-minded
idea which suits the interests of like
the high-end call girls is a luxury
belief because the women who are
suffering for at the opposite end of the
social Spectrum yeah
and I guess
um you talk about the Nordic model for
this what is that so the Nordic model is
when you uh decriminalize Sellers and
criminalize buyers decriminalize sellers
oh so it's not illegal to be the
prostitute but it is illegal to be the
person seeking a prostitute yeah and
this is good because it well it reduces
the demand and criminalizes the powerful
people are either men who buy the thing
but it doesn't criminalize the poor
destitute women who are forced into it
yes which is historically often being
what's done that the the women are the
ones who get locked up and the men go
free which is obviously horrendous so it
flips that okay
psychological difference with the
differences between men and women what
is uh what's uh what's the kind of worms
here
um and I guess how is it relevant to
this this whole debate again it's that
population level thing
um I mean it the the degree of
difference varies quite a lot depending
on what trait you're talking about
um one of the ones that gets the most
attention I think wrongly is
um
the idea that men are more interested in
things and women are more interested in
people
um do you remember James Day More Google
memo oh yes so I can't remember this
like five years ago maybe it was younger
James Damon was a
um
a technician at Google and I can't
remember his role of Google he worked at
Google and he wrote um a memo which he
circulated among his colleagues
explaining the fact that the fact that
there's an underrepresentation of women
in certain roles at Google
and an overrepresentation in others so
you see more women in things like human
resources Communications kind of roles
which are more people focused and then
you see more men in more say at the
engineering roles
he said that this could be explained by
the fact that there are
um these average differences between
what men and women are interested in and
if you're looking at the the very
furthest Tale on the bell curve in terms
of say how interested you are in hard
Sciences you are going to expect to see
more men at that tale because
because of the gap on average between
the two sexes
his argument was completely sound his
research was completely sound he got
fired because it was just you're not
supposed to say this I think you're
specifically not supposed to say this if
you're a man and you work for Google
um
um so as a woman who doesn't work for
Google's reasoning here yeah he's right
um I also think that and he says this
himself in the memo that the difference
is the average difference is not massive
so you will expect to see men and women
across the whole range of
people things you know distribution the
same is true of something like
agreeableness women are a bit more
agreeable than men are but there are
still plenty of women who are really
disagreeable employment who are really
Incredible or neuroticism like there are
lots of traits which see a gap but the
Gap isn't massive right
um something like aggression though the
Gap is massive like the average Gap yes
yeah okay as well as and but then
obviously the Tails exactly the vast
majority of people in prison are men
yeah 95 in this country
um because and there's also an age SKU
there so
um men and women but it's most striking
in men are by far the most
um violent women in their teens and 20s
and then the Violet fending falls off a
cliff
um which I don't think can be explained
except biologically right I don't I
think if you I think if you just want to
explain it on the basis of socialization
which is often a
um
uh a theory that feminists have have
pursued to say that men are particularly
in childhood are socialized to be
aggressive through things like toy guns
and that we should be focusing on you
know I think fine and clearly there is
some truth to that and clearly
um there are certain childhood or other
environmental experiences that can make
violent offending more likely but then
also you look at something like the age
distribution in
violent offending you think hang on why
would a 20 year old
be many many times more likely than a 40
year old to commit this kind of offense
unless what we're kind of talking about
here is hormones
which is trivializing a little which is
simplifying it a little bit because
clearly there's a lot of there's a lot
going on in terms of our biological
makeup but
the gap between
um
violence violent aggression in men and
women
is massive
and
very important if you're trying to if
you're thinking at the population level
and and the I mean the the the trait
that's most relevant to me and that I
write about most in most detail in the
book is what psychologists call
sociosexuality
so that's your interest in sexual
variety
it's not quite the same thing as sex
drive okay but um someone who is high in
the trait of um
has unrestricted sociosexuality as
psychologists would say is someone who
is
really interested in having lots of
Partners wants to jump into bed with
someone as soon as they've met them well
um
um is much more likely to say things
like having sex without love is fine
um basically someone who's having an
absolute ball post sexual Revolution
right is someone who is high in socio
sexuality and Men I don't think anyone
will be surprised to hear are higher on
average in that trait than our women and
the Gap is fairly significant and at the
Tails it's the most marked
so that's why sex buyers are almost
entirely male
would it not be reasonable to say that
this is all a result of socialization
like women have been oppressed
throughout history and [__] shamed and
stuff and therefore of course they're
going to be lower in sociosexuality
um compared to men for whom like even
though we'd like to say the sexual
double standard doesn't exist it still
does men are conferred higher status by
having multiple partners
um all of those things surely mean that
actually maybe the sociate sexuality Gap
doesn't doesn't put doesn't really exist
and it's just a it's just a relic of uh
socialization
so that's the argument yeah that's the
alternative to my thesis the problem
with that argument is
um
if if socialization is responsible for
the Gap and the socialization is
remarkably consistent across time and
place
like it seems like every culture decides
to flip you know it's like you flip the
coin and oh it's just coming up heads
every single time what are the chances
because if you look at there's some
really great studies done of um
sexuality across cultures and everyone
finds that men are higher in it on
average and I mean I think to some
extent we've done an experiment in the
west post-section revolution in whether
we could socialize it otherwise
um and if women are encouraged not just
permitted but encouraged to have sex
like men maybe they'll do it
um and the argument that I'm making the
book is that
um
a lot of women are trying pretty hard to
have sex like men and are being quite
strongly encouraged by the culture and
by
the men in their lives to to attempt the
high sociosexuality kind of way of being
um one of the things I examine at one
point is
uh articles in women's bags
about how not to catch feelings like
guides to how to have sex without
emotion and they're always
framed very carefully in a
gender-neutral way so that well you know
of a person didn't want to catch
feelings from their relationship with
another person how would they do that
but it's very obvious that actually what
we're talking about here is women
getting emotionally attached
to in these sexual relationships and and
not wanting to like thinking oh man this
is dry this is like holding me back
because I want to be having this
um I want it to be behaving as if I had
unrestricted sexual sexuality I want to
be
um like participating in hookup culture
like a man but I have these like
niggling feelings
which keep getting in the way which I
think is I mean unless you want to say I
suppose it's socialization the childhood
socialization goes that deep that it
can't be undone
maybe but I think Occam's razor says
it's just the difference there's a
difference that's like the by far the
simplest explanation for what we see
across the world
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by wework now this is particularly
exciting for me because I have been a
full paying customer of wework for the
last two years now I discovered it
during you know when the pandemic was in
the on the verge of being lifted and I
spent like the whole year just sort of
sitting in my room making YouTube videos
but then I discovered wework and I was a
member me and Angus my team members we
were members of the wework in Cambridge
and they have like hundreds of other
locations worldwide as well and it was
incredible because we had this fantastic
beautifully designed office space to go
to to work and we found ourselves like
every day just at nine o'clock in the
morning just going to wework because it
was a way nicer experience working from
the co-working space than it was just
sitting at home working these days what
me and everyone in my team has is the
all access pass which means you're not
tied to a specific wework location but
it means you can use any of their
several hundred co-working spaces around
London around the UK and also around the
world and one of the things I really
love about the co-working setup is that
it's fantastic as a bit of a change of
scenery so these days I work from home
I've got the studio at home but if I
need to get some focused writing work
done and I've been I'm feeling a bit
drained just sitting at my desk all day
I'll just pop over to the local wework
which is about a 10 minute walk from
where I am I'll take my laptop up with
me I'll get some free coffee from there
I'll get a few snacks and it's just such
a great Vibe and you get to meet cool
people I made a few friends through
meeting them at wework and it's just
really nice being an environment almost
like a library but kind of nicer because
there's like a little bit of soft music
in the background and there's other kind
of startup Bros and creators and stuff
in in there as well and it's just my
absolute favorite co-working space of
all time it's super easy to book a desk
or book a conference room using the app
and it's a great place to meet up with
team members if you're going to
collaborate and you'll live in different
places they've got unlimited tea and
coffee and herbal teas and drinks on tap
and they've got soundproof booths in
which they take Zoom calls and meetings
anyway if you're looking for a
co-working space for you or your team
then I'd 100 recommend wework like I
said I've been a pain customer for
theirs for the last two years which is
why it's particularly exciting that
they're now sponsoring this episode and
if you want to get 50 off your first
booking then do head over to we.com
forward slash Ali and you can use the
coupon code Ali at checkout Ali to get
50 off your first booking so thank you
so much wework for sponsoring this
episode when I was in university in my
third year because you know in uh in in
medicine you can do that or whatever you
want in your third year so I ecology and
one of our collector courses was the
psychology of individual differences and
this was comparing things like men
versus women in all sorts of things
personality IQ controversial different
race differences between all these
different things
and a lot of it was like well you know
when it comes to things like aggression
when it comes to things like
sociosexuality there's a clear
evolutionary psychology psychology
rationale for this yeah and you know
Homo sapiens has been around for 300 000
years it's really been an eye blink uh
in terms of human history where the pill
has been a thing yeah so of course our
evolutionary brains are somewhat
hardwired to you know for women to be
choosier about who they have sex with
and men's mating strategy to be like
willy-nilly you know yes whatever
exactly
um and yet if if it felt like even even
at the time at University where
like I had friends who were doing like
anthropology and like art subjects and
stuff where one of the one of the essay
titles in like the third year exam was
uh biological sex is a lie discuss and I
was like whoa I mean gender okay like
fair enough but like are we really going
to talk about chromosomes and biological
sex and like uteruses and stuff as if
they're just completely mythical and how
hormones have absolutely no effects at
all and it became very unfashionable to
even suggest that there was a
evolutionary psychology explanation for
stuff to the point that anytime I bring
up the idea oh but like evolutionarily
the response would be look that's what
the men's rights activists say you've
been reading all this red pill stuff
haven't you
um but it sounds like it just is the
simplest explanation that yeah there is
a difference and let's acknowledge the
difference and let's work with it rather
than trying to I guess override our
evolutionary instincts yeah I think that
the so I do I do I do completely get and
sympathize with the
um feminist hostility to evolutionary
psychology and indeed to sort of
scientific sexism so-called in general
it goes back a long way there have been
some pretty egregious examples of
historically of sort of attempts to
rationalize
um the subordination of women
um the missing five ounces was the
phrase that was used by some 19th
century psychologists to describe the
fact that given that women had like
given that women have smaller brains
because women are smaller
um that missing five ounces on average
explained women's intellectual
inferiority
when of course we know that like if
you're not going to let women go to
university like they're going to
struggle to completely like making
groundbreaking achievements in
intellectual Fields so like that's
cleared an example and we found I mean
you mentioned section IQ we know that
the average iq2 men and women is about
the same even if the range is bigger for
men so
I think that is a clear example of the
fact that it wasn't it was an
environmental limit
but
that doesn't mean that we have to
dismiss all scientific research into sex
differences and all of the evidence for
it and I think Evolution I think
evolutionary psychology is just it's
just a morally neutral
field of study
and we can do with it whatever we
want to do it's it is an inconvenient
field of study if what you want to do is
kind of
deny the existence of human nature per
se and build kind of
build Utopia off the idea of us being
blank slates uh we aren't blank slates
though is the problem and we kind of
have to deal with what we've got and my
view is that look at this sex
differences exist and that's
then that's just
the fact it's not it's not a good or a
bad thing but it is what we have to work
with and I think actually there's a
strong case for using evolutionary
psychology
to feminist ends
in some situations what's that
so for instance
um
if we accept the difference in
sociosexuality between men and women and
we accept the fact that actually it's
going to be very difficult for women to
um be persuaded or persuade themselves
into imitating a more masculine style of
sexuality
then
I think that the feminist argument
against hookup culture becomes
irrefutable
whereas if you're working with a blank
slate model and you're saying well all
of this is socialized all of this can be
undone you're kind of giving fuel to the
um to the Hugh Hefner's who are intent
on persuading women out of their like
natural and self-protective instincts so
we talked about two areas in particular
in which men and women are on average
different so aggression and
sociosexuality
um another area that I think I think you
talk about in the book but um again
there's a a specific example that I'm
thinking of that brings us to light is
that I was having a conversation with a
female friend
um a couple weeks ago months ago
um and
there was this this person that we were
talking about this guy was going on a
date with a girl and well okay cool
God's going on a date with a girl that
they met online no harm done like let's
yeah okay cool
um but then it transpired that the chap
in question had in fact booked a hotel
room
for the night around where they were
having the dates just in case things
went well okay now in my mind I was
thinking all right fair enough
and in her mind she was thinking oh my
freaking God this is just completely
unacceptable like oh this is in in
innate sense of revulsion at the thought
that a man would have the audacity to
book a hotel room just in case things
went well and of course it would be
consensual and stuff yeah and he's like
we were we were a bit puzzled by this
she and I because it's like we had a
very clear difference in me not batting
an additives I mean obviously it's gonna
be consensual uh and is there as an
option and you know worst case he goes
to his hotel room who cares yeah but for
her it was like this real sense of
revulsion and I feel like this idea of
kind of getting the ick and like feeling
that innate sense of revulsion about
certain things yes uh we'll we'll give
women a very different response than it
does it just to men yes what's what's
going what's going on there yeah the
interesting isn't it and the ick is one
of those things that you read about in
women's mags and again
um
we'll actually know is generally
represented as being a woman thing
women get the air con Mentor not to get
the and what's been described there
basically in colloquial terms is um the
fact that women sexual disgust threshold
is a lot lower than men's
and that's one of those things that you
can measure quite objectively because
you can measure people's disgust
response through things like
sweating and heart rate
um and it's much easier to trigger in
women than it is in men
um there's interesting evolutionary
theories around this I mean it might be
partly to do with mate Choice the fact
that women care more about it than men
do it might also be to do with the fact
that women tend to be more vulnerable to
sexual disease so women are more easily
grossed out by signs of disease in a
potential sexual partner and that might
be because
um for nature apprenticeship sex just
means that women tend to be more
vulnerable to disease transmission from
sex and also
that women are more likely to pass
sexual diseases onto their children
through pregnancy and breastfeeding so
there's maybe a more like deeply
embedded
instinctive
protective Factor there
um whatever the cause it does seem to be
it does seem to have some kind of
evolutionary cause it could be several
um and yeah it is deeply felt and I
think it's something that um
um I mean partly because I think we're
very invested in our post-sexual
Revolution culture in denying the
differences between men and women
pretending that we're very similar I
think it's something that um men and
women struggle to
um
sort of instinctively comprehend that
difference I think this often is what's
going on with conflict between
in cells and feminists in that
like
I think from
from a certain kind of maybe naive Intel
perspective the fact that any woman can
go out into the street or anywhere
really and pick up a sex partner within
minutes is seen as heaven on Earth
you're living exactly what I'm dreaming
of the ability to attract sexual
partners whereas from women's
perspective they're like I don't want to
have sex with some random guy on the
street like that's terrible I dream of
being
um like left alone by creepy guys who
who scare me
but there's like a visceral level in
which each group can't quite understand
the other yeah because we have very
different instincts around sexuality
yeah
um I remember sort of
anytime this guy I think in the last
year or so this is the sort of
conversation has been had like two two
or three times with with female friends
of mine where they've mentioned that
like you know they've got all these male
friends and then at one point one of the
male friends will just throw away You're
gonna drop a throwaway comment that oh
of course every guy in your friendship
group would would be down to have sex
with you if you if you were up for it
and they'd be like what what like it
completely completely blows their minds
because they cannot imagine anything
about that you cannot cannot imagine a
world in which you're like but I I see
these guys as my friends they're like
they're like brothers yeah and they're
just
yeah there's almost no girl who ever met
who is actually appreciated the fact
that men were willing to have sex with
basically anyone as long as they meet a
reasonable threshold for attractiveness
whereas that's just absolutely not the
case for women and there are like even
studies where they've gone out on the
streets and done this like
yes and 100 of the women's I know yeah
to to random requests from men whereas I
can't remember the figures but it's
probably not majority of men say yes
unless they're in a relationship or
something like that I mean it's worth
bearing in mind that
um men do have kind of different modes
of sexuality so what men are not
consistently behaving like cads
um men have a low bar when it comes to
Casual sexual partners when as you say
pretty much you know Julie Bend or
feminist friend of mine she um likes to
collect news stories about men having
sex with inanimate objects because they
do sometimes come up in like local news
and she has a little like informal
collection of man found having sex with
a pile of leaves man found having sex
with a bike you know like imagine it and
it's happened right so clearly there is
an extent to which men can be persuaded
to basically shag anything like living
or dead but
men aren't like that though about like
potential wives right so when it comes
to choosing a long-term partner men are
very high standards and
um you know care deeply about the whole
package not just how attractive a woman
is with everything else about her
um
women don't seem to have those two modes
women basically will have sex the
criteria that women look for in a casual
partner and look for in a long-term
partner are the same criteria
um and actually often women will
have sex with a casual partner in the
hope that he'll become a long-term
partner
um down the line whereas and I I think a
lot of women don't realize that men have
two modes which can cause heartbreak
because if you've if you're if you're
having sex with a man with the belief
that you're on wife track and he doesn't
think that yep then that's really
painful
yeah
um yeah this is another one of the
things where I think there's just such a
clear like basically everyone every man
knows that there are two thresholds yeah
there's the threshold for a good time
and there's the threshold for an actual
long-term relationship yeah and whenever
women are confronted with at least from
what I've seen it just okay again it's
like really mind-blowing it's like oh my
God men are the worst men are trash like
I can't believe this is the thing and
um this idea that women don't have two
modes though so uh
what about the Trope of like women uh
you know wanting to have sex with the
pool boy or the personal trainer but not
actually wanting to you know those
people on aren't husband material
they're good time material is that not
the same as sort of cat versus I guess
it happens although it is interesting I
wonder if it happens more in fiction
than in real life because it's
interesting that um
men and women tend to cheat for
different reasons so men and more like
could cheat on their Partners basically
just because they're horny there's no
there's no difference between the level
of reported relationship satisfaction
between many cheating men who don't
cheat
it's not because they're unhappy in
their relationships they're cheating
it's they're cheating either because
they're unusually horny or they're
unusually like unscrupulous morally or
both
um whereas for women women cheat when
they're unhappy in their relationships
and they don't otherwise and that are
you know on average whatever their
exceptions but that seems to be because
what women are doing the purpose of
cheating for women is a Lifeboat to line
up the next relationship because you're
unhappy in your current relationship
um so you normally wouldn't therefore
cheat with the poor boy
if your husband is wealthy normally
you'd be cheating with someone who seems
like a like a viable alternative partner
slightly different motivation to play
there okay interesting um
there's a great book by David boss I
mean David boss in general is a
fantastic reading yeah I recently read
the evolution of Desire yeah which is
really interesting really interesting
this latest book is called bad men oh
I'll check it out very very good yes and
he covers a lot of this in great detail
nice and and provides the wealth of data
that is very persuasive yeah like I I
have a surprising interest in in this
genre the topic I I just think it's it's
it's this combination of like
really taboo and controversial and also
like clearly there's this whole like
scientific and like sociological and
evolutionary psychological backing
behind the things that we don't like to
talk about that we feel around are
controversial yeah um I think it depends
on your personality and how much you
enjoy that I find it thrilling yeah like
to to sort of go behind the scenes and
be like yes
of course this is true
um but some people find it confronting
it depends yeah
um Okay so we've talked about kind of
two two core differences between men and
women psychologically on average again
with all the caveats uh aggression and
sociosexuality yeah and I feel like
those are sort of the two pillars that
form the rest of your thesis around
sexual Revolution being potentially not
as good a thing as we might have liked
yeah so had sort of if we accept that
okay fine let's say that Louise is right
about all the evidence the weight of the
evidence suggesting that in fact men are
on average more aggressive and more
sociosexual than women what does that
mean about
stuff regarding sex relationships gender
Dynamics it means that the people who've
actually won from the sexual Revolution
are high status men
not necessarily all men
because there are some there are you
know quite a lot of men if you're
familiar with the data that comes out of
dating apps which shows that
um it's a minority of men who tend to be
getting all of the attention from women
and the majority of men are getting
almost nothing
um I think that holds true generally
generally post-sexual revolution in
terms of like who is actually like the
Hugh Hefner's are not representative
right the Hugh Hefner is a high status
attractive men who can get loads of
consequence free sex
um they're having a great time is is
that launcher on the women's side as
well no because what women do you're
familiar with hypergamy as a term so
um women are much more
invested than men are in general in
having
um relationships with people who are
with men who are high status than
themselves just called hypergamy and
what that means in practice on things
like dating apps where you've got a very
large pool of Partners to choose from is
that women tend to all be flocking to
the top
um the men at the top of tree so I think
the figure is it's like on Tinder 10 the
10 most attractive men are getting 60 of
likes okay from women and then the
bottom 10 are getting like zero it
doesn't match up neatly based on your
attractiveness level women are all kind
of aiming yeah
um and because on Tinder and in general
in a kind of casual sex culture those
men are not obliged to stick to one
woman
they don't get married and then remove
them as holes from the dating Marco
right they have simultaneous
relationships or they have back-to-back
relationships what those men are
basically doing is they are like
living a polygonus yeah life right where
they're accumulating multiple partners
okay and the women aren't necessarily
aware of this right right but so you end
up with some men who are having
um
lots of Partners most men are having
none and the women are also miserable
because they're having these like brief
unsatisfying relationships with
attractive men who then ghosts them but
this idea of for example like the top 10
of men are getting likes the 60 of the
likes yeah is this not also true of like
the top 10 of most attractive women are
getting 60 of the likes or is it all
women are inundated with likes
because men yeah thinking of every
single female friend I know who's on
dating now just like yes dozens if not
hundreds of matches I mean you'll have
you know you'll have a bit of a range
but it doesn't accumulate at all in the
same way yeah like pretty much pretty
much any woman on Tinder is going to
have some options available to her which
is not true for men yeah yeah I remember
there's a there was a time a few years
ago this was when back when I was a
medical student
um one of the chaps in our year uh was
like incredibly attractive and we just
went on as Tinder one day and it it was
just like something out of this world
it's like every single right swipe was
oh you've got a match a good match
you've got a match you've got a man and
we were all just like oh my God like
it's just so totally different an
experience whereas any any like most
female friends that I I have who have
made accounts on Tinder or hinge I've
just been like oh I've got 143 matches
I'm just like wow incredible yeah Rob
Henderson talks about
um uh he he's um written a sub stack on
dating apps and he talks about a friend
who
a very attractive male friend who was
one of an early adopter of Tinder and
had 21
000 women match with him over a period
of some years so much so that Tinder
identified him as being like a stellar
user and they gave him perks which then
meant that he accumulated even more
um in contrast to another friend who
wasn't that bad looking but was you kind
of a bit below average he had seven in
the same period so the inequality is
amazing I've read that if you if Tinder
was
um a nation-state and you're assessing
it's like inequality it would be one of
the most unequal countries in the world
oh only fans would be the most unequal
country in the world because only
because only fans creators are also
subject to the kind of burrito law and a
minority of only fans creators basically
taking all the money and the the median
only fans creator has 30 subscribers
hmm so I mean it sounds like the
conclusion there is like uh unless
you're our top 10 10 alpha male
um then you're unlikely to have a great
time on dating apps yeah I think it's
broadly that experience and I think in
general I I think that applies to other
things too I mean
so I guess
something like porn I mean so some men
would say that
um the fact that you now have copious
availability upon on every platform
going
um and that there isn't nearly as much
stigma associated with it as it has been
historically is great
I don't know though if
I think actually there's an increasing
feeling among men that actually porn is
bad for men
yeah there's a lot of uh men's men's
personal development YouTube channels
that are recently peddling this
Narrative of like porn is really bad
delete all the porn like stop spending
all your time on yeah yeah and no fap
just becomes more and more influential
with time
um so I think that even though you know
the the argument of making the book is
is counter to this that the argument I'm
taking aim at is the idea that the sex
revolution has been fabulous for women
and it was all about freeing women
I don't think that's true
I think that it's been much more to the
benefit of Hugh Hefner than Marilyn
Monroe right but
it's also not the case that the sexual
religion has been consistently amazing
for men I think the sexual revolution
has been good for a minority of men who
are able to enjoy its fruits you know
but even then I think it has a shelf
life
I think it's probably really good fun to
be the man with 21 000 matches on Tinder
when you're in your 20s and 30s you're
not going to have that in your 70s
though and I think that if you make the
decision
to just sleep around and not ever
um get married not ever have children
and so on
that might be great for a period when
you're young I think you will regret it
later though generally so I would say
that even Hugh Hefner
had a grand old time you know in his
prime but he he ended up being a pretty
pathetic figure by the end
so yeah someone in the 70s having lots
of that is just a just a little you know
it's very pathetic isn't it yeah yeah
exactly what was the story with these
and sorry and how do we landed the idea
of that consent is not enough
is a actor comedian and he um he was at
the center of a metoo scandal which
attracted a lot of attention I think
because it was a particularly sort of
controversial example which means that
people people love talking about
controversy so I think that's why it
became prominent
um he went for a date with a woman
who
um they went back to his house
afterwards she
he kind of subtly pressured her into sex
she didn't she he wasn't violent or
forceful at all
she didn't say no but equally she wasn't
really into it and he
sort of
persisted in trying to persuade her even
when she was lukewarm and they ended up
having sex and then late and then she
went home I think she texted him later
and said something like that was weird
and he said sorry something on those
lines and then sometime later she wrote
an anonymous account or a pseudonymous
account of what had gone on
and it became the source of controversy
because the question was whether or not
she had really consented to the sex I
think reading her account that it's
clear that she did consent in a legal
sense in the as Ansari jumped to the
legal bar
the legal bar however is very low I
think that the the reason that she was
distressed and the reason a lot of women
identified with her account in relation
to their own experiences is because he
he behaved legally but he not like a
gentleman right but she she
that kind of vocabulary is so
old-fashioned it's so unfamiliar to
anyone who's kind of operating a liberal
feminist framework
she couldn't use words like and
gentlemanly or chivalry or even I think
words like respect or dignity you know
words like these are a little bit kind
of so she talked about consent and
everyone else talks about consent and
that became the subject of discussion
because that was the only vocabulary
left available
I think that the consent I think that
the the focus on consent as the sole
framework for determining whether or not
sexual behavior and good is bad is good
or bad is completely inadequate there
are so many there's so much gray area
between
good sex and consensual sex
hmm I guess sort of consent is this sort
of legal bar yeah but then we're saying
that beyond that there is actually a
moral or gentlemanly chivalrous
respectable dignified bar exactly and
you're not allowed to talk about that
because that's just it just feels a bit
weird like why would you bring up like
gentlemanliness that Hawks back to the
heroes of I don't know the 1900s or
something yes
um and therefore when trying to critique
Aziz ansari's Behavior or otherwise
if the only word you're allowed to use
is consent it means that everything just
is like okay the people who are like
prosies I'm sorry the only thing they're
arguing about is was a consent yeah to
which the answer is probably yes but
like kind of gray area but probably yes
the people who are anti-season sorry or
like was it consent to which they think
the answer is probably no but like gray
area but probably no and consent becomes
the Battleground by which all of these
things are I figured out and I think
we're all talking past each other
by doing that because actually I don't
think consent is the source of dispute I
think the the source of dispute is
whether or not he behaved morally
to which I think the answer is no he did
also behave normally right like this is
a completely standard
style of encounter I mean that was part
of the reason why it was so widely
publicized because a lot of women can it
resonated with them they'd had those
kind of experiences where you know
because the expectation particularly
because he's famous she's not famous you
know the the expectation was that she
would put out on a first date
because that's normal
and she didn't really want to but she
also didn't really have the confidence
to assert
her reluctance which is why she kind of
went along with her and I think and I
think it's a really good example of the
fact that
understanding this solely in terms of
individual decision making just doesn't
quite work because we're all functioning
in
an environment where where there are
Paths of least resistance
which are determined by the culture and
if the path of least resistance when you
go on a date with a celebrity is to put
out on a first date then of course that
is what the direction which you're going
to be pushed
even if you don't really want to but
again how do you talk about that in
terms of consent like it's just these
are completely inadequate
framework yeah yeah one of the um one of
the passages that you quote quote in the
book I think it's um this this girl who
had a consensual sexual encounter
um but didn't really feel great about it
and tried to convince herself that it's
it's just sex yeah I think that phrase
It's just sex
um highlights a lot of what yeah what's
what's going on there yeah so this is a
um an anonymous I think metoo
contribution for a woman who had had sex
with a guy who actually you know she
fancied him there was no coercion
involved
like it was kind of fine it also was
left her feeling Dreadful
and I think often I think that was often
actually the case with a lot of me too
stories I mean some of the metoo stories
were straightforwardly Criminal
but not necessarily like a lot of them
were to do with having kind of
sex that was sort of fine and and was
supposed to feel okay according to
what's considered normal
um but women felt terrible about it and
they didn't quite know why they felt
terrible and it was difficult to
articulate and often
the way of resolving that feeling was to
talk about
was to suggest that somehow consent had
been absent under the man in question
had
had not respected consent in some way
rather than you know as we were saying
to say that he had behaved in an
ungentlemanly way or moreover to say
that actually maybe there is something
wrong in general with the Norms maybe
maybe the whole expectation that women
will be having emotionless sex
is setting women up to fail and that we
shouldn't be surprised to discover that
women are feeling terrible after having
sex it actually is basically not suited
to their self-interest I mean
particularly when you think of it in
terms of the physical imbalances like
the whole hookup culture set up
grossly unfair the fact that you've got
women are the ones who have to worry
about pregnancy women are the ones who
have to worry about hormonal birth
control women are the ones with risk of
violence
women are the ones who are much less
likely to want casual sex massage much
less like to seek it out women orgasm a
lot less than men do like every in every
possible way like women end up on the
losing side of this Arrangement so why
is it being normalized I mean my
argument is it's not it's not feminist
in the least
and I I suspect as well that the reason
that it's been normalized as it has is
partly with ideology it's partly through
such disenchantment it's it all feeds
back into liberal feminism and
liberalism in general
which is sort of invested in seeing us
as atomized individuals who are
basically indistinguishable from each
other in terms of sex I think also part
of what's going on is to do with this
hypergamy thing it's the fact that women
are competing generally for the most
attractive men
that is the 10 of men who are getting
most of the offers of sex
and it does mean that those men have an
amazing amount of power
in the dating market and whereas
previously in a monogamous marriage
system
they would get married and they'd remove
themselves from the dating market now
they are like they can basically live an
informal polygamy
um which isn't actually codified in law
but that's that's basically what they're
living
which means that they can demand from
women
the kind of sex they like
which is casual polified etc etc
and so women feel like they have no
choice because you know if you if if you
don't put out someone else will
hmm and I think often it's easier to
resolve that feeling you know it's not
difficult to find women who will say
that they like this that they find it
empowering etc etc
um I think the reason for that though is
because it's a much much more appetizing
kind of narrative for what's going on
you don't want to think of yourself as
being someone who's just been kind of
funneled into dysfunctional styles of
of sexuality and behavior it's much
better to think of yourself as being an
agent
um and there will be examples where
that's true
but equally I know so many women who
have lived like that as younger women
and then and later have changed their
minds and thought actually I was I
wasn't doing that for good reasons I was
I was pressured in you know various ways
um Bridget for tazy who's a um American
podcaster
a comedian she I spoke I spoke on her
podcast she read the book and she she
wrote an essay about it last week
actually it called I regret being a [__]
because Bridget used to wear for Playboy
as a writer
um and
um very much lived this like sexually
disenchantment life of having lots of
casual hookups
um and now says she said that she opened
the first page of my book and just burst
into tears because
she she completely recognized that
mindset of sort of persuading yourself
that this is good
even if it feels wrong this is one of
the disputes I had with Ayla in the
unheard interview because
her emphasis and like I get it on a
rational level is that some people are
well suited to this kind of
casual relationships some people aren't
the task is to work out which category
you're in and to like carefully examine
your own responses which is fine and I'm
sure for some people that works the
problem is that human beings are
amazingly good at self-deception
and if the any of the any of the high
status thing to be is the woman who
likes the casual
style of sex then of course you're going
to sort of
you have an interest in like assigning
yourself to that category and ignoring
the extent to which you you feel
differently of course that used to be
the flip side right it used to be that
women the pressure was on women not to
have premarital sex and women who
actually wanted to would have suppressed
that feeling in themselves
but this is this is the power of culture
um
so presumably you're not advocating a
return to
pre-1950s morality where there is a
clearer you know the the vehicle of
Shame is used strongly against women to
disincentivize
multiple partners and Casual
relationships as it is with men but like
less so
um presumably that's that's not what
we're trying to get to no and actually I
do worry a bit that the um I think that
there's a correction happening now or
starting to happen in the this kind of
the sexual hyper liberalism has swung so
far on the other in One Direction I
think that there is starting to be a
spring back and there's starting to be a
reaction against it particularly among
gen Z you hear a lot more kind of
criticism of sex positivism on things
like tick tock and I do worry a bit that
that could take the form of [__] shaming
and let's say women who went on only
fans in like the great only fans Fest of
2020 are gonna really pay the price
later I don't want that to happen like I
really sincerely don't I don't think
that the it's kind of like with the
Nordic model I don't think that the
mechanism for
um
change should be directed at
criminalizing or or shaming women who've
actually been taken advantage of I think
I think I want my shame to be directed
at the Playboys
the problem is that obviously on like a
societal scale it's quite hard to
coordinate yeah
hmm welcome to your action points uh in
in just a moment um I'd love to talk a
little bit uh I'd love to talk a bit of
a way to turn a phrase about sexual
assault and sexual violence and I wonder
if we can start with kind of your
background in this because I know that
you have a background in this yeah so my
first job out of the University was
working in the red crisis center what
does the Rape Crisis Center do Center do
uh it depends on the center but
generally
um uh a emotional support helpline
um helping victims through
the criminal justice process providing
therapy to victims and things like
support groups and so on my job
specifically was doing one-to-one
support with teenage girls and I also
did
um consent workshops in schools and
trained to helpline volunteers what
prompted you to go into this career path
or this job after University I was I was
volunteering on it
um at University
and then a job came up
and I had actually intended to stay in
the charity sector but then I sort of
became a journalist by accident a little
bit so here I am so what was your
experience in this Rape Crisis Center
and I started volunteering there I was
doing interviewing women's studies and I
found the distinction between like the
theory the feminist Theory and feminist
reality extremely jarring
um
things like the course that we did on
introduction to feminist philosophy
had so little in it about very little in
it really about violence or biology
um almost nothing about motherhood
it was always kind of angels dancing on
the head of a pen stuff about defining
women and gender presentation and all
this kind of stuff and I've always just
felt like I don't really care about
things like lipstick and drag and I
don't know all this performance stuff it
just doesn't seem too very important to
me whereas um what you see on the ground
in Frontline feminists
um
services
like an amazing proportion for instance
I did not know this for a sort of
underground amazing proportion of child
sexual abuses committed by stepfathers
so much which is something that
evolutionary biologists have paid close
attention to so a step parent is about a
hundred times more likely to abuse a
child than a biological parent it's
called the Cinderella effect
and the theory is that it's because they
don't have any biological investment in
the child and actually if anything the
child might be a con a threatener
competitor within the household
um because they you know monopolize the
resources of the new partner yeah
yeah there's that quote from I think
Stephen Pinker that you cite in the book
can you remember what that what that was
I think you said something like it's the
it's the single most
the single clearest determinant ever
found
for predicting child abuse
yeah which just feels like I mean
someone listening to that is going to
think oh but like I know a step parent
who's amazing is that fine yeah agreed
um there are loads of exceptions we're
talking about minority but it is also a
very apparent on paper the extent to
which it raises the risk okay so it
sounds like one of the things you you
learned working in the Rape Crisis
Center was
difference between kind of feminist
Theory and kind of reality on the ground
yeah step
parents abusing their children way more
yeah I mean one example also just the
use of victims
the modal rape victim is 15. 15. yeah
surprisingly young right that's
surprisingly young yeah and the
proportion of female rape victims who
are over the age of 30 is in the single
digits
so basically your period of risk is from
adolescence to 20s
surprisingly young it does kind of like
it kind of makes sense actually with the
sort of The Stereotype I mean all
stereotypes are kind of based in truth
that's why they become stereotypes and
but it's not it doesn't really make
sense within the more academic
explanation for rape which puts much
more emphasis on
um
power
and socialization and patriarchy and all
these kind of social forces rather than
thinking about
possible biological origins of sexual
violence
like if you
the age of
the age of rape victims
matches perfectly
with the age of
um attractiveness to Men of women
right teens and twenties like that's why
porn is all women in their teens and 20s
right that's why teen is consistently
the most popular category is because
it's associated with fertility like and
if
if you think that the motivation for
rape has nothing to do with sexual
desire that it's about
um violence and control and power it
doesn't really make sense but I think if
you
if you recognize that actually such a
desire is in there too
than it does and so I think that I think
what happened in my thinking is that
seeing noticing these things noticing
these Trends and things like
demographics
made me think hang on I don't think the
full story is is there in the academic
feminist explanations for this phenomena
yeah and and so
you mentioned so I I remember when I was
thinking when I was in my sort of
undergrad undergrad years
um around 2013-ish was when rape culture
started becoming a thing that people
talked about yeah and within a period of
like a few months it seemed like every
college and every University Society was
putting on sexual consent workshops
which
were always a little bit of a like a
uh the the impression I got was that
people felt that they were a bit
pointless but like no one wanted to say
that they felt that they were a bit
pointless because I mean obviously there
was an epidemic exactly obviously you
know there was an epidemic of like rape
going amongst college campuses
apparently especially in the US but like
also apparently in the UK yeah every
woman you would speak to has had some
kind of experience of sexual violence
every man you speak to says hey all my
friends are gentlemen like they wouldn't
act like that clearly there's a
difference clearly there's something
going on yes so you said that you've ran
sexual consent workshops at schools
rather than University but it's much the
same thing yeah what's going on there I
mean I think that they are fine I don't
I think that
um
I think it's good for institutions to do
them I also don't think they do what
people think they do generally because
what people think they do is they
educate would be rapists you know they
that like the the idea being I suppose
that
[Music]
um
rapists don't know it's wrong or they
don't know that what they're doing is
rape or that there's some sort of like
information Gap that needs to be bridged
then it's not normally a phrase like
that because when you phrase it like
that it sounds really stupid it is
really stupid I think that what can
certain workshops actually do is they um
they provide sign posting for victims
you say if this happens to you this is
what you do they
um they make it clear to victims what
the law is and when
things that have been done to them like
that they're allowed to object they're
allowed to go to police Etc
and I think it's also useful in an
institution to make certain boundaries
very clear so for instance I think it is
good for schools to tell kids that if
they share revenge porn there will be
disciplinary consequences because then
if they do they can't claim that they
didn't know right fine so I think all
this stuff is good
the problem is I think that
um
sex rape is not a consequence of
misinformation or misunderstanding
generally I think it is a consequence of
sexual aggression combined with
opportunity right and one of the things
about universities I mean there's
actually evidence to suggest that women
who are at universities are less at risk
of sexual violence than women who aren't
if you're just for age so the idea that
campuses are like uniquely
um infused with rape culture doesn't
really seem to match up with the data
it's also though the case that um
you know there are certain environments
to some extent
found on University campuses but also
elsewhere which are provides a lot of
opportunities for would be rapists
like for instance environment with loads
and loads of drunk women
is like
the perfect environment if you are
sexually predatory and you're looking
for
and you're looking for victims
yeah so one argument that I've heard is
that this idea of
sexual assault and rape being
sort of violent aggressive men finding
women in an Alleyway or in a club is not
actually the majority of rape but the
majority of rape happens within
relationships or within families like uh
I don't know the date on this to what
extent does that hold true in yours so
the most common type of perpetration is
an acquaintance
um it is true that boyfriends and
ex-boyfriends particularly ex-boyfriends
um are also very common perpetrators and
it is also true that sexual violence
within families
is more common than I think anyone
really wants to admit
um so there are yeah there are a lot of
different circumstances and it's true
that the violent rape in an Alleyway is
a minority of cases I mean stranger rape
in general I think is like
less than five percent I can't remember
exactly the figures but stranger rape is
quite unusual
um although women have a very intense
fear of it it's you know it motivates a
lot of
um
uh safety work that women do when
they're out
but yeah it is less common than
something like an acquaintance
I guess if we if we put those situations
aside and we if we and we then think
about the college campus yeah where
like
clearly
there's this
I want to say gray area but like
depending on what side like depending on
your perspective it's not it's not
particular grade it's just black and
white between
women having
essentially being sexually assaulted by
dudes in a college campus and it seems
like
telling women to not drink alcohol
uh uh feels like profoundly victim
blaming ye yeah yeah and
one of your
um kind of conclusion conclusion points
at the end of the book where
essentially that the chapter is entitled
uh listen to your mother is
um you know the the idea of get drunk or
high in private and with female friends
rather than in public or in mixed
company yeah now when we were kind of
doing research for this for this podcast
like this was a point where you know I
just I've been discussing this book with
loads of friends over the last like
several several weeks since I've since I
first came across it this idea of
it sounds like
Louise Perry is saying that the solution
to sex uh just male sexual violence is
to tell women to stop drinking which
feels like not the right answer somehow
so like what's it's probably the most
controversial line in the book of the
book that has got a contrast stuff in it
um yeah I mean I don't say women
shouldn't drink I say women shouldn't
get drunk
around them I don't know
so that is slightly different but I yeah
I know that's really counter-cultural I
completely agree it wasn't
counter-cultural until you know 1980s
1990s that wasn't considered
counter-cultural
um culture has had quite a lasting
influence in terms of
um valorizing women drinking like men
and getting like
blind drunk in public
um I mean it's one of those things where
I think
I am very sensitive to the victim
blaming risk and I and I and part of the
part of the reason for low prosecution
rates of sexual violence is to do with
rape myths being embedded in the
criminal justice system there are a lot
of other reasons too but that is one of
them
um and so we you know we do have to be
sensitive to that and I'm and I say
completely unequivocally that a man who
raped a drunk woman is the only person
at fault in that scenario
having said that in practice this is
what we tell our friends this is what we
tell our sisters and our mums tell their
daughters right in practice everyone
knows that it's not a very good idea
to incapacitate yourself when you're
around men that you can't necessarily
Trust
the problem is just that it's not you're
not supposed to say it not publicly you
say it to people in private you don't
say it publicly and I think the problem
with not saying it publicly is that um
not all young women do have people who
will tell them
in private there's a certain hypocrisy
there I think hypocrisy as in in that
you can privately as a feminist choose
not to get
really drunk and you can tell your loved
ones to do the same thing but you can't
advertise it as a
as a guideline you have to you have to
say publicly you know of course women
should be able to behave as men do and
of course they should you know this
naturalistic fallacy like of course it
should be possible for women to do to do
anything in public and to be completely
safe from predators but the fact is that
they're not
and I think that any kind of Norm which
encourages women to behave in a way that
will will result in
lives being ruined by sexual violence
I just think it's dishonest
so I felt I felt it needed to say it
even though I knew that it would get
backlash because it's true and I think
that everyone does actually know that
it's true it's like we're sexually
disenchantment you know there's the
rhetorical level where you say
you should be able to do whatever you
want and sex is like playing squash and
then there's help people behave and the
Gap I think shows us exactly how how
true the rhetoric really is
do you think like
what would our kind of Steel Man
feminists say uh is is the is like a
good reason why we don't have this
rhetoric in in public
because
um men will hear it and they will
conclude that it is that drunk women are
asking for it
and jury members will hear it and we'll
conclude that
um drunk women are asking for it and
that it will feed into these
um negative stereotypes around rape
victims and I agree that that is a risk
but I also think that
there are trade-offs involved which are
really difficult
this was an area in which
and I just I just didn't have the
vocabulary or like education or just
like understanding to actually fully
appreciate the the different sides of
the debate because every woman that I
spoke to about this book and about the
fact we were doing this interview and
sort of you know the people who who read
it or looked at the the headlines that
said basically Lewis Perry's advocating
don't drink around meant broadly does
kind of simplify it but just like
yeah I mean like we'll we all know this
like we'll tell our friends we'll tell
our daughter that we all like like
everyone knows this to be the case yeah
but it felt like there was something
damaging about
saying about actually saying it out loud
and I guess that's the sphere of well it
just feeds further into it like it's
already hard enough to get
um convictions for rape yeah does
encourage it does putting a line like
this in print actually contribute to
this potentially getting worse for women
I also think that it's much more
important to prevent sexual violence
than cons than successfully prosecute it
right if given the choice it's really
hard to prosecute sexually I mean for a
whole bunch of reasons some of which is
to do with Colin's liberal justice
system but some of which is to do with
the nature of the act like if
if if the line between illegal and legal
sex is entirely based on what happens
between two people in a room with no
Witnesses it is just very very difficult
to prove the presence or absence of
consent so I think that we're never
going to have 100 prosecution rate no
matter how good the system is which
means I think that it's more important
to try and
you know
if you do a poster campaign saying rape
is bad you shouldn't rape you're gonna
prevent precisely zero rapes
because that's not that's not what's
motivating rapist right whereas
um you know a style of post campaign
that police forces occasionally release
and which is often gets feminist
backlash is things like look out for
your friends in public if you're out
drinking make sure you know where they
are make sure they get home safely in a
taxi and it often gets criticized in the
poster campaigns even get withdrawn
because of feminist criticism but I
think
you know yes maybe it's the case that
women know this already and they're
already doing this maybe not I mean
teenage girls are pretty stupid
sometimes teenage boys are pretty stupid
sometimes like this is just the nature
of being inexperienced and not having
not having already learned it I mean I
dedicated the book to the women who
learned it the hard way because I think
that the the current setup
is kind of all around these slightly
unspoken truths and the the existence of
these differences which we kind of know
about we don't talk about you know the
fact that men have two modes of
sexuality right the fact that men will
will treat women as if they're really
cheap if given the opportunity the fact
that getting really drunk around strange
man is risky all this stuff that is true
and we all kind of adults know
but we don't necessarily say and we
don't necessarily tell young people and
so you have to go through that process
of discovering for yourself and you and
I think the problem is that there will
be
girls in particular who during that
process of discovering it for themselves
get really unlucky
there was a common refrain when I was at
University which is don't tell women how
to dress teach men not to rape yeah
um which I think
was trying to get at the frustration
with
saying hey look men are just trash or
ten five to ten percent of managers
trash anyway so like girls watch out for
yourselves
it's like why should we have to do that
why should we have to say that like the
problem is clearly with the men and not
with the women yep
um Marley that's completely correct
morally yeah it's just in practice
but it's difficult
I mean I think the how people dress
thing is a little bit of a
Canard I'm not really aware they're
actually being that strong correlation
between what women wear and their
likelihood of being assaulted as far as
I know it it's not
the length of your skirt isn't isn't
very relevant
um I think what's much more relevant is
is basically ending up in scenarios
where
that five to ten percent of bad guys
have an opportunity so like the example
that I give in the book is um
of um a dating advice column
in the times where a woman's written in
saying
um I'm interested in BDSM I want to give
it a go what shall I do and the reply is
basically well
obviously you know consent is very
important and men have to respect your
consent given therefore what you should
do is you should go on the internet and
you should advertise the fact that you
really want to be strangled and then you
should invite men to contact you and
then you should go to their house and
have consensual
strangling sex together
and you know that it's incumbent on them
to respect your consent and I'm like yes
it is incumbent on them to respect your
concern however what do you think is
going to happen if you go on the
internet and say I really fancy a
strange man strangling me in his house
like I just it just the light
the impracticality of that kind of
politics yeah drives me around around
the bend you know because I'm like
I I agree that it should be possible I
mean it should be possible for us to do
all sorts of things without like having
to protect against Bad actors
but
it seems like it's only in this area
where we we basically insist that young
women should fake it till they make it
fake it till they make it they should
behave as if
there are no Bad actors because they
have a right to behave as if there are
no Bad actors
in the hope that down the line
there won't be any more and men will all
be taught not to rape and then it will
be safe yeah but I can't just like
sacrifice the bodies of these exactly
yeah exactly
yeah
um
one of uh
one of my friends who looked at your uh
the the the final listen to your mother
chapter can I describe this
um
said that it's it's it's it sounded like
the advice is quite defeatist and not
particularly empowering to women yeah I
wonder what would be your response to
that yeah defeatist is sometimes the
expression I've heard
um hetero pessimism this is home I've
heard as well pessimism I mean basically
just
I think that there has been I think that
there is increasingly a feeling
um among feminists of all stripes and
men and women of all Stripes that like
there is something wrong with the sexual
culture that people aren't very happy
um men and women that sexual violence
has not gone away by any means and maybe
this the whole kind of Freedom
experiment
hasn't worked out very well
and I think that the
the very utopian style of thinking
in the second wave
the idea that we can tear down the
family and we can kind of
re-socialize everyone and and live in
like new experimental ways I think was
very
very Valiant and very interesting but
also pretty much failed utterly and I
think that the point that we've well the
point that I've got to at least in
thinking about all of this stuff over so
many years is to think look I think that
I think that actually what we're faced
with is a much more difficult challenge
than we might previously have recognized
I think that some of this stuff is baked
in
to an alarming degree it doesn't mean
it's hopeless but it does I think mean
that we have to be kind of working
around reality
rather than trying to redesign Society
on the back of an envelope
which also means that if we're looking
for systems that seem to be more or less
protective and produce more or less good
and bad outcomes what we have to choose
from is not the status quo and some like
imagined perfect alternative or we
actually have to choose from is the
status quo and other Alternatives that
have been trying tested in previous
times and places because those are ones
that have actually
worked like if you're imagining a
utopian system that no one has ever
tried before
there's probably a reason for that it's
probably because it's not actually
possible
um can I take a quick tangent before we
come back to the action points um
another particular controversial thing
that you say in the book uh is that uh
basically and feel free to correct my
paraphrasing but all BDSM is basically
bad yeah
um and uh I was on a I was in group
holiday with some friends a few days ago
and we were talking about the book
because we were doing this interview and
they were all like oh come on like you
know I can be a totally nice guy uh but
you know still have some like you know
it's it's consensual and like BDSM is a
thing and like clearly I'm into it and
she's into it and it's like sometimes we
swap roles and stuff yeah uh so it felt
to be controversial to say like yeah
Louise position seems to be that like
actually it's it's it's always bad so
what's what's going on there
um I mean I think it's bad at several
different levels
um I work for a campaign group called we
can't consent to this
um what we do is we document cases where
um women have been killed in the UK UK
women have been killed and their Killers
have claimed in court that they
consented to violence which they
consented to the violence which led to
their deaths so like the sex game gone
wrong defense the reason that um my
friend and colleague Mackenzie founded
the campaigners because she'd noticed
that this was becoming something you'd
see in the papers more more often and so
she went away and actually documented
how often this defense strategy was
being used and found that it was
becoming more frequent and also that it
was being used often with success so men
were able to it's always been men who
use this defense we've never found an
example of a woman using it
um they're able to get to get away with
a man's thought of conviction rather
than a murder conviction are able to get
very short sentence you know something
three years or something right for
taking a woman's life this is what we're
talking about and the problem with this
defense is that the the woman isn't
there to give her side of it necessarily
and very often what you're talking about
in these cases is like
uh a man who's picked prostitutes a man
who seems to have had like a long-term
abusive relationship with his girlfriend
um you know all sorts of scenarios which
actually look indistinguishable from
just like normal femicide but they're
able in retrospect to spin this
narrative and say oh she was asking for
it and she can't she can't say otherwise
and the fact is with BDSM that actually
but that is what it looks like from the
outside there is no way of telling
without knowing what's going on in
people's minds that this is whether this
is domestic violence or whether this is
consensual Buddhism they look identical
and from a from a legal perspective
that's very difficult how are you
supposed to tell the difference one of
the cases I talk about in the book which
is an important piece of English case
law Emmett involves a woman who suffered
terrible injuries
inflicted by her husband went to the
doctor because she needed treatment and
the doctor very unusually violated
patient potentiality and reported this
to the police
when it came to court she refused to
testify
either way
her husband claimed that she'd consented
to it as part of Sex and the court
believed him and I think
maybe that's true
my Spidey sensors tell me that it that
it isn't right like what's actually
going on there is domestic abuse and the
nature of domestic abuse is such that
women are what any victim of domestic
abuse male or female will often say that
they can censor things and will often be
you know
lulled into a false narrative spun by
the abuser because that's the nature of
psychological abuse that it wears you
down and that it and it did it
um dissuades you from leaving or from
objecting or from you know the
psychological component of domestic
abuse is just as just as
um
just as permissive and just as
dangerment dangerous as the physical
element
and I think that this is the problem
that you get to with BDSM I mean I I
can accept in theory that there are
people who genuinely do it with absolute
consent and are entirely responsible and
there is really no harm done to anyone
involved
but also in practice there are so many
people you can find who have been
previously part of you know the BDSM
community and have had terrible
experiences and will say in retrospect
that they were taking advantage of that
they you know that they that there was
mental illness at play often that there
are like varying degrees of coercion and
abuse that are often quite subtle
and this is and I think that the more
this is normalized and made mainstream
the more incidences like that you will
come up with I mean so something like
choking for instance which is now
20 years ago was really neat she was a
niche within the BDSM Community I mean
like responsible BDSM practitioners will
say that the choking is actually really
dangerous and you shouldn't mess around
with it
um and yet now it's on the front page of
every porn platform in the world it's
completely mainstream you've got I can't
remember the numbers exactly but it's
something like half of women in their
20s or say that they've been choked by a
partner at some point you know and some
of those women are consenting some of
them not
but that's what's going to happen if you
make it a really mainstream thing you're
going to end up with this being
like a routine part of sex and once
something is part of the sexual script
like it's considered to be a normal
a normal thing then the default setting
is to do it the default setting is to
say yes even if you're not sure and
actually it makes you feel bad and I
think as well that it
I would say as well for
for men who do it men who are asked to
do it by their Partners I mean that's
something that I hear often you know but
my girlfriend asked me to choke her
I'd say I mean her motivation for being
asked to choked I mean it's partly to do
with the fact that um
a lot of women do are are turned on by
like a bit of submission right
that's very common it probably has
something to do with Evolution it's like
it's it is much much more common for
women to take the sub role than the Dom
role in any kind of video scenario and
vice versa with men
um I don't think that's necessarily a
very like I don't necessarily a terrible
thing we have to dissuade people from
doing but I also think that like choking
is a really bad manifestation of that
instinct it's like a particularly
um particularly aggressive and
particularly risky thing to do it's
difficult to kill someone accidentally
through choking insects but it is quite
easy to injure someone and in general
it's just not something you want to be
encouraging it's extremely gendered form
of violence is the second most common
form of murder used by men against women
in this country and overwhelmingly
victims of non-fatal strangulation
it's in domestic relationships it's
female victims male perpetrators right
so like it's just it's not good news and
the problem with normalizing it is that
I think as well for men like it
re-inscribes
dysfunctional arousal patterns
if that makes sense which is I think a
problem with porn as well I think this
idea that like
our sexual desires are fixed in quality
and quantity and what you have to do is
just like siphon off your sexual energy
in a like periodically I think that's
wrong I think actually we need to
understand this as being like a feedback
loop
um I mean I don't mean feedback Luke
Bryan This is being reinforced by orgasm
and if you are like
if you are
um
inscribing in your own mind the fact
that choking is your thing choking turns
you on you're gonna like want more and
more of it you're gonna end up going
down an increasingly dysfunctional Road
this is one of the reasons why men using
porn often ends up being really bad for
the men even though I think porn has
other problems but you know just in
terms of the user experience is because
you end up like
your sexual desires become weirder and
weirder
because you're exposed to weirder stuff
and you kind of reward the stimulus
and you end up potentially going down a
really like Grim road which the porn
platforms are perfectly designed to
encourage yeah
and there's the thing that you say here
of um
you know I think this one is
particularly uncontroversial chivalry is
actually a good thing we all have to
control our sexual desires and Men
particularly so given their greater
physical strength and have average
higher sex drives
um then the point after that is
sometimes they're not always you can
readily spot sexually aggressive men
there are a handful of personality
traits that are common to them
impulsivity promiscuity hyper
masculinity and disagreeableness these
traits in combination should put you on
your guard I wonder if you can just kind
of like elaborate on that what did like
how I I guess how
Typecast is the sexual offender sexual
assault or kind of vibe
um so that combination of traits I think
comes quite clearly from the literature
looking at um sex men is in prison and
how they tend to differ from the general
population and those traits are more
likely to be found in its exponents in
prison obviously you're not going to be
quite representative sex offenders
because only about one percent of sex
managers go to prison
um so they're not going to be
perfectly representative that is a
suggest that there is a there is a trend
yeah in that regards so one of the one
of the interesting things I thought
about that list hyper masculinity
disagreeableness impulsivity
um maybe not promiscuity uh but at least
but certainly those three uh sort of
seem
somewhat similar to kind of the dark
Triad traits that yeah dark trades for a
great predictor of sexual aggression
which seemed to be particularly
attractive to particularly younger women
yeah and so it seems like we have this
weird it's a bit unfortunate yes what's
going on there
um yeah I don't know why they would be
but yes it does appear to be the case
that some dark trial traits can improve
your prospects on The Dating Market
um I guess in terms of being
you're effective at manipulating people
things like that yeah and so I guess if
you were giving action points to your
daughter or something it would be a case
of even though you might find these men
somewhat more attractive sometimes yeah
then but actually this is you know when
you're 18 19 17 you don't necessarily
know what's good for you so like you
know be a little bit careful please is
this is that the kind of vibe yes I mean
just anecdotally I don't know about
research on this but um
I think that there's a lot of variation
between women in terms of how much women
are attracted to the doctor I trade so I
personally have never found them
attractive but clearly anecdotally it's
the case that some women do like the
kind of the bad boy image and it is a
yeah it's it's a it's a risky combo
in terms of the risk of sexual
aggression hmm
one of the uh one of the other ones is
uh and again somewhat controversial
don't use dating apps mutual friends
convert histories and punish bad
behavior dating apps can't
I totally get the rationale here because
mutual friends can indeed vet histories
and punish bad behaviors but dating apps
can't and yet if we look at the stats it
seems like you know the majority of
couples are now meeting or dating apps
yes do you actually are you actually
advocating for a blanket bounded dating
apps for or or something yeah I mean I
think the base I I think people probably
do mostly agree with me that they're not
they're not the best way I think the
problem you've got though is that now
people are so it's so much become the
norm yeah they're doing anything else is
difficult although I do have female
friends who've like made a conscious
decision not to use dating apps because
actually it's not worth it I mean I've
just I've just actually filed an essay
on this
um and I spoke to loads of friends in
depth about their experience of using
the apps and like one friend told me I
was really struck by this because she's
like
super beautiful super attractive in
every possible way
has been on the apps for years and years
still hasn't found a boyfriend and she
said that of 95 of the dates she's been
on when she's met via apps have not
ended have not had a second date
and another friend who said as well that
she she tried the apps just they weren't
working and then she ended up actually
having a relationship with someone who
initially she'd seen his spoke who was a
mutual friend link she initially she'd
seen his photo and thought and like
thanks and she met him and was really
attracted to him and it worked out
really well and both saying like I don't
think the apps are very good I mean
they're good in the sense that they give
you access to a very wide pool
particularly if you're in London or
something like there are so many single
people within your vicinity but in terms
of quality
I don't know and I think also that
because I mean we spoke about the whole
hypogamy problem on the apps but also
the apps they tend to encourage a sort
of anonymous
Vibe which encourages bad behavior
um if you don't have any link to anyone
like
there are basically no consequences if
you misbehave
um everything from ghosting through to
sexual assault or basically no
consequences and so like I totally get
the appeal and I also totally get the
fact that I'm like happily married so
it's easy for me to say this I didn't
meet my husband by the apps but also
that was the period before they were
normal
um
equally though I think like the
downsides are pretty Stark and again I
think particularly for women if you're
one of these guys who are getting
thousands of like matches on Tinder it's
going to be pretty hard to resist yeah
but I guess as women like
I I mean every single woman that I've
ever spoken to has had one or more or
even more than 10 bad experiences on
dating apps oh yeah whereas very few men
I know but would have said that they had
a bad experience because I guess like
kind of worst case scenario for a dude
is it's the date is kind of boring right
what's getting all right for a woman
it's just like really bad it's like a
serial killer yeah that you um there's
this film I can't remember what it's
called there was this film that came out
last year or earlier this year
um that was about
um a woman who meets a guy on a dating
app and all seems to be going well but
then it turns out he's actually a
cannibal serial killer
who like kills women and sells their
meat on the black market
and it's supposed to be accommodate this
film yeah apparently it's I have not
actually seen the whole thing but
apparently it's it's like horrific to
watch but I thought it was really
interesting that this it was female
writer female director it's very much
like told from the female perspective
and I thought it was really interesting
that this was like what the female
imagination collectively was coming up
with there's like the the film about
dating apps because obviously it's
everyone it's everyone's worst nightmare
but it's also I think expressive it's
just like a general
horror when I text when I text a few my
friends earlier this week because I was
writing this essay to ask for quotes
about Tinder and because it's the 10th
anniversary of Tinder oh right yeah I
was just like inundated with
their terrible let me list all the like
horrible things I've experienced on them
yeah so now yeah
um I guess last thing I'd like to ask
you about so um you have uh recent well
I guess a year and a bit ago had uh a
baby son yeah
um and you have like action points for
what you would tell your daughter or uh
but do you yeah do you have any action
points for what you would tell your son
how like you know how should men behave
in the sexual and dating Marketplace so
it is something that I've not really
written about it but it is something
that my husband and I talk about a lot
because obviously our son's a toddler so
it's not irrelevant but it's something
it's something to think about as a
parent I think that um
I think that it is really important to
channel
um
like youthful male energy which is which
is like a different thing from you know
if we're accepting the men and women
we're in a different thesis right we're
accepting that
um men again have higher Sex Drive is
generally higher energy aggression all
this kind of stuff like
you can't suppress that and I don't
think you I don't think it's wise to try
but you can Channel it in Positive
Directions so it's like one of the
things that my husband is personally
very keen on is martial arts and
um he's done on like kickboxing and
boxing over the years and he thinks it's
very important for boys to do that like
girls too it's fine I've done a bit of
martial arts as well like it's good fun
it's good exercise but he thinks it's
really important for boys because it's a
way of like taking that instinct towards
fighting and being like destructive and
energetic and whatever and and taming it
and making it a positive thing
and I think that principle in general
is a good one yeah your relation to boys
um I guess there is one thing I want to
end with which is um in the book let me
see if I can find it uh you've got this
sort of list of four questions
uh that women should ask themselves and
that mentions themselves um I don't know
if you can run them off the top of your
head but I'll I kind of crowdsourced
them from people who are from Friends ah
here we go this is this this is a this
is a good one I did it because people
love quizzes yeah people do love quizzes
um so I'll just kind of read this out by
kind of quoting quoting from the book
and then I just love for you to kind of
Riff on these for men and women and
listeners or viewers can answer these
questions for themselves and uh feel
whatever you want to feel
um so uh if you're a woman who's had
casual sexual relationships with when in
the past you might try answering the
following questions as honestly as you
can one did you consider your virginity
to be an embarrassing burden you wanted
to be rid of
two do you ever feel disgusted when you
think about conceptual consensual sexual
experiences you've had in the past three
have you ever become emotionally
attached to a casual sexual partner and
and concealed this attachment from him
and four have you ever done something
sexually that you found painful or
unpleasant and concealed this discomfort
from your partner either during sex or
afterwards
and you're going to say that if your
score is zero then congratulations
you're high sociosexuality and good luck
have allowed you to successfully
navigate a treacherous sex sexual
Marketplace but if you answered yes to
any of these questions as I suspect you
probably did you are entitled to feel
angry at a sexual culture that has set
you up to fail
yeah I guess having having done 50 of
these podcast interviews now how do you
how do you feel about these questions
and this is actually the first time
anyone's brought them up but I because I
think yeah I think those are I Source
those questions from talking to lots and
lots of friends
um many of whom had had sort of gone
through this journey that I describe of
you know previously basically like
relying on COPE in relation to
so the like casual sex is empowering
narrative
um and then later being like
I can't believe I put up with that I
can't believe that I you know believed
all of that and I think that those
questions do sort of drill down into
that
self-deception Factor
which is very difficult what you want to
think
I'm doing this for myself
I I sincerely want this but actually
yeah yeah
yeah and I think uh one of one of the
things when I want to just kind of run
run these questions by by a few friends
is that like basically the answer from
men for all of those questions is just
like well obviously not like it's it's
just not even a thing it's not even a
consideration almost and yet it clearly
is for like every single female friend
that I've run this question but has
always been like oh yeah what's that
average score
um I didn't say I didn't I didn't I was
just like more than yeah not zero
um yeah yeah uh there was there was one
you had aha uh where's one for men
said that male one's like yeah again
crowdsourced from male friends who were
pretty Shifty about it but yeah
um I I persuaded them here we go
um so you kind of talk about this uh
this situation where it's it's sort of
like friends with benefits and the woman
has quote feelings for the man and the
man's just like that he kind of knows
but he's always seems it seems a bit
surprised but like what really she she
caught feelings what I had no idea
um and you say that uh these men seem to
be genuinely bewildered by the fact that
the women that they have been having sex
with for many months are unhappy in
these pseudo relationships and the women
seem to have drifted into this
Arrangement not realizing how little
regard that Partners really have for
them this is a tragedy of mutual
incomprehension however I cannot help
but Harbor a sneaking suspicion that
many men perhaps all do realize that
operating in quote CAD mode is not
actually harmless male readers who have
ever had heterosexual casual sex might
like to ask themselves these questions
are counterpart to the questions I
addressed to female readers earlier in
the chapter
1. have you ever had sex with a woman
you'd be embarrassed to introduce to
your friends
two have you ever failed to contact a
woman after sex three have you ever
suspected that your casual partner was
becoming emotionally attached to you and
failed either and failed either to
commit or to break off the relationship
and four have you ever encouraged a
woman to do something sexually even
though she showed reluctance the answer
to all of these questions ought to be no
but a culture of casual sex incentivizes
men to do such things and generally with
no social penalty if anything men who
[__] and Chuck quote good time only
women can often expect to increase their
social status among their male peers at
least in the short term
yeah shift your responses there yeah
yeah again very much non-zero yeah very
much feeling like
like again this Aziz and sorry situation
yeah it's just so ridiculously common
yeah that yeah and I remember when that
article came out it was like a real like
Oh My God moment for like everyone I
know who read that article because
everyone knew that it was such a common
situation and the language of consent
was it not appropriate to actually be
able to have that conversation which is
probably one of the good things to come
out of me too in that I think that there
probably weren't men who were paying
attention to it and who maybe were doing
this stuff on a mild level who were like
oh man I'm like I'm slightly guilty of
this I think the only problem though is
that in general when we're sort of
um
trying to appeal to men in this way the
men who are listening are the ones who
are already pretty good like Harvey
wines he doesn't care yeah right like
he's not listening
um and obviously there is there is it's
a good thing to nudge men who are like
like well-intentioned towards behaving
better but there is an extent to which
like the guys who are listening in the
guys who are already on board yeah
so you do
um anyway thank you very much
any final piece of advice you would give
to any young men or women listening to
this or watching this podcast that's
quite a lot in the book I mean my
sometimes people ask me what's my like
one underlying advice to women and I
think what it is is the problem is
sexual
the polynomial feminism and sex positive
feminism as as an ideology is that it
really discourages women from listening
to their instincts and if anything
you're
because the pressure is only to be
open-minded tolerant like not to be hung
up on like silly traditionalism and all
of this kind of stuff
um that can translate when it's combined
with female agreeableness as we
discussed earlier in the show women more
agreeable than men on average it can
translate into just like suppressing
feelings of distress
and anxiety
and trying to train yourself out of
those responses and I think no if like
if you're if your instinctive response
is any kind of distress
any ideology that tells you that you
shouldn't be listening to that is not a
good ideology to follow
so I guess that's my like
That's the basis of all of this trust
your gut listen to your instance don't
let's Society tell you that your gut is
in fact wrong yeah pretty much nice well
thank you very much thank you so much
all right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye